to
what the flip is up my people of the
world
go
july 11th my my my
beautiful summer day welcome everybody
to the h3 podcast the number 12 podcast
in the world that's right according to
the latest edison poll
on our way up though for sure oh yeah
thanks for being here everyone sorry i'm
a little bit late today
you know we all recovering from covet me
ila and bruce and then theodore caught
covet on like thursday or friday i think
friday i don't remember
and so it was just a long weekend man
another long weekend he's actually today
finally
feeling better oh that's good
yeah
that he was back to his
rambunctious self this morning okay
but the weekend was long
boy
god
yes so we all got it now
but
unfortunately i wasn't able to attend
but all these guys went to
ace fest the long awaited
now
did everyone i know lina didn't go were
you there olivia so everybody went
everybody everybody but lean up yeah
yeah just not me
wow
and well i'll i have pro we have a whole
report ready and i don't want to spoil
anything for you guys but it's shocking
i'll say
probably it's shocking and let me just
show you guys we got a signed poster
because you guys went to the meet and
greet right and then this is a signed
poster did they sign it in front of you
or they hand it off
they hand it off but periodically you
can see them signing some okay so so
this is the real deal it's legit now
what are you supposed to do with this
it's just a random family that you don't
know
do you hang it we should frame it and
have it in the office
you ordered a frame oh did you nice
that's what's up there you go put that
next to my trailer review yeah yep damn
my mama
what uh you know what's funny i don't
know what's this detail on the wall but
it just looks like a folding
crease
didn't it yeah it's not but it's like a
weird wall detail no it's totally it's
perfect condition huh blood boiling
blood baller
so there's that and boy i'm just so
wait did they give you this yeah yeah
what
that's expensive one of these like fill
folders i mean vip experience this is
the ipads
so what did they hand they just handed
you this
it's outside of that but yeah it's it's
on top and yourself is there anything
else in it no how much does one of these
cost these are these are not cheap i'm
being serious because i have a lot of
experience sending stuff
this is a very
hard
vanilla folder or whatever you call it i
i buy those and they're usually like a
hundred bucks for maybe 50 of them or so
hundred bucks for 50. that's what i'm
saying it's expensive two bucks yeah
that's really easy okay
impressive
very impressive
but but anyway that's coming up soon but
boy i'm pretty excited about it i gotta
say proud of all you guys who went out
there to the pit of the [ __ ]
the seventh circle of hell known as
lancaster that's right yep
105. oh thank you
thank you to hellofresh by the way for
sponsoring us go ahead zach sorry i was
just saying it was 105 and windy
nice and nice yes so when it's 105 the
wind isn't exactly refreshing
no it is not yeah
oh i'm so excited guys
you know but before we get into that
there's a few things at the top of the
show i want to mention
one being that this thursday july 14th
we are doing a
50 off every dang thing on the website
except for the gentle thrills one which
is the one that just came out that'd be
you know
but everything else on the website
except for gentle thrills everything
wow
it's 50
off
at 7 14 this thursday the owners of
teddy bears have lost their minds
yeah who are those guys oh wow the world
has gone to [ __ ] but at least you get 50
off everything at teddyfresh.com
it's like a little you know tough times
are hard
it's kind of messed up because like you
have inflation which is forcing all the
prices up it has affecting our company
like the price of cotton has gone up
like a thousand percent or something
crazy shipping his way up fuel his way
up thanks joe brandon
and um
and also i just feel like times are
tough so we said we want to you know
give everyone an opportunity
to hook themselves up now
yeah interesting yeah
uh for starting july 14th and i think
we're going to do it for a week of 50 of
everything so there you have it wow and
of course my huge plug was this
did anyone see this over the weekend
oh i saw it all right unfortunately this
well this was what i was up to all week
and taking care of theodore
sick with covet and i was just next to
him making tick tocks
howie posted a straight up
prolapsed anus bro on tick tock it was
nuts man it was
crazy and
i so here's what happened
um this is the only
it's such a huge prolapse i feel like
you would think that this sale tag is
too big but it's not it really covers
just just
the juicy part like all of this
yeah
so my question is i don't know the
context of this photo is this a prolapse
of pleasure or a prolapse of medical
because like i don't know the the whole
posture like how do you blow your ass
through pants because his pants is
ripped i don't think it was it's
pleasurable by any no i uh i think it's
a prolapse of pleasure i think this is
this are you talking about
that's got to be horribly painful
doesn't it but why prolapse of pain that
is painful absolutely but why is there a
giant rip and his asshole's just poking
out of it it just seems like a fetish
kind of thing i mean
it's definitely a fetish thing yeah yeah
it seems like a fetish
or the only other thing is it looks like
he's in wrestling pants maybe
or like weightlifting maybe he busted
through and then they had to cut it open
oh
maybe
i love can you do me a favor if you're
comfortable
can you reverse engine that
that image and see the origin or
whoever's comfortable with that i don't
want to force anyone to do this i mean
the origin is obvious no it's definitely
some kind of a fetish poor thing well i
said that and everyone thinks i'm crazy
what do you think he's like power
lifting and his like pants just bust
open and he's [ __ ] prolapsed
it's possible he prolaps and then and
then the doctor had to cut
the
like a bullet wound you know they cut
your shirt cut it open
get access to it quickly but then what's
with the photo
exactly your ass ah that's a good point
why would you to me it's a prolapse of
pleasure
i wish i could show you guys obviously
it's so inappropriate
which is why it was so funny but like
it's huge man and it's like purple and
gnarly and it looks like uh
oh
it's like a busted out flashlight dude
it's so gnarly
also i i love how uh how he's wearing an
ellen's shirt
but here's why it's so specifically
pretty interesting that it's howie
you know i did his podcast recently and
he's so sensitive he's so pc he's so
clean
and yet here he's on tick tock posting
[ __ ] the most horrific [ __ ]
anyone seen it was up for like seven
hours had three million views oh my god
what he said was um
do we have a censored one where you can
watch by the way yeah i put up a poll
asking the audience if it's pain or
pleasure and it's literally 50 50.
exactly 50 50. oh it just took the 49.51
to me
i just split
i don't know i think it's got to be a
pleasure prolapse
i just don't understand how
you could get into this situation on
accident
yeah
you make a good point of like why does
the photograph exist
yeah if it's if it's a medical thing
who's going back there and snapping a
photo right
sex because there's this thing and the
like i was listening to howard stern and
there's this thing called fist fest
right where they literally it's they
fist they fist each other and what they
love is what they call like a red rose
and i'm sorry this is so gross
but they get off on the prolapsing of
the anus
and like the inside how it's red and
[ __ ] and they they love that
it's called fist fest and so i'm
thinking that this might have something
to do with that okay well you know maybe
you're right maybe i was just unaware of
this uh corner of uh because it just
looks like
yeah bro i don't know someone's saying
it's both i don't know oh
[Music]
i can't look over there
do you find anything interesting
uh that's one way to put it but not
related all right
yeah it's a lot i'm just saying i'm but
i'm not showing you guys anything so you
know we're almost up to 10 000 votes and
it's still exactly 50 50.
well okay i know it's painful right
obviously but i'm saying was this an
accident or not let's put it that way
yeah was it an accident i don't think so
right i think this is by a prolapse by
design okay i may have found
finding the origin
okay what did you what do you got um
what could happen to your well they had
the same image and it says uh
it's an example of what could happen to
your anus when you uh lift too much
and uh the effects that could have on
your colon
and that's definitely how he's photo
okay because he is wearing a
weightlifting kind of outfit but you
could blast your [ __ ] out like that
just from lifting weights that seems
kind of dramatic
is that possible
can you prolapse from lifting weights
another reason you have to exercise
according to what abe just posted severe
workout can cause prolapse men may risk
rectal prolapse
women may risk vaginal or rectal
prolapse damn
vaginal prolapse that all just comes out
that's what i'm saying guys exercise is
[ __ ] bro
walking around prolapsing their [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm not prolapsing my ass sitting and
playing skyrim i'll tell you that
let's
you're muted
yes they're ripped wide open
actually and i'll be honest with you the
rip was like
there was no loose fabric it was like a
clean
taut
rip all the way around here
yeah you know there wasn't any loose
fabric which makes me think maybe
i don't know maybe it wasn't cut because
it's spandex and it's busted wide busted
wide open i don't know man
but okay interesting there you have it
oh no
yeah there it is but anyway um
i started um
duetting it on tick tock because i
thought it was [ __ ] incredible man
i did like three duets
i think i'm the reason howie
it finally got removed because
my account has some kind of like
extreme content filter where if i post a
video
i can't and i try to share it show to
the guys immediately it will say this
you can't share it this is under review
every time i post the thing so there's
some kind of thing that makes it get
reviewed before
and so i made like three or four duets
to this
two of them got um
graphic image warning
and then eventually one of them got
removed for
community guidelines uh violation
and then i went to howie's and then that
one was also removed so i think it was
me delete i was having too much fun with
it
damn
damn damn oh they all had coveted
warnings yeah because he goes
here let me see i'll play you guys the
whole thing this this was so incredible
oh see i think i think this poodle shows
too much somebody no like you could see
[ __ ] stain on his pants well you maybe
just play the audio then because we they
saw the picture you see what i'm saying
though you showed too damn much we were
kind of debating that earlier i thought
i thought it was it's a lot right yeah
well here's what he says
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
it's funny but you can't post a
prolapsed anus man on tick tock and
howie mandel of all people
of all people
ah so i did one where i was like
just like the prolapse was on the top
and then i was on the bottom like
playing a game where you have to catch
like a cat is trying to catch yarn or
something
and then i did one where i was wearing
glasses and they were in the reflection
of the glasses and i still wonder if i
might be able to post that one just
because
it's pretty subtle
but i don't know i don't want to get
banned over this [ __ ] because i know i'm
right on the edge man on tick tock man
so oh okay maybe says apparently the
anus belongs to a champion weightlifter
is that more
maybe actually i found some more
information on that and
that is apparently a myth and it's been
proven to be false oh there's a one
website snoops.com is this great
prolapse rectum reel and it says false a
big one they say
no such injury has been uh described to
occur as one at any weightlifting
competition uh
no the image is real but it's not from
weightlifting yeah right so this has to
be that would make this video even
funnier than i'm watching because it's
like very serious it's uh yeah i saw
that video too yeah i'm sure you can get
some injury down there but to this
extent seems kind of nuts
but anyway um my favorite was the
glasses and i'm maybe we could upload
that from for members or something
yeah i put them behind the scenes
are what i i don't know if that would
get it that might actually get us a
strike i don't think we can put it
anywhere on youtube it's such a shame
what about instagram stories do you
think i get busted for putting it there
yeah [ __ ] man
it's [ __ ] up i can't share my my
my art with you guys anywhere
discord members discord yeah that's a
good idea
no
even and we're just getting no's on that
one up yours
people are saying is this real yes this
is real it had
and there's now a whole ecosystem of
people
with ptsd being like did anyone else see
the prolapsed anus on howie's tick tock
people saying twitter yeah i mean
twitter doesn't really give a [ __ ] oh my
god
we can post that post on twitter right
now
wait so wait if you guys want to see it
here i have the original i have all of
them
let me let me send you guys all of them
and then you can post them to or twitter
this is great
so here's the original twitter's a rat
hole
yeah thank you yeah you're just mad
because you got [ __ ] suspended [ __ ]
we'll see who cancels who
so here's to here they are here there
okay i sent both of them in the podcast
chat so now if you guys really want to
see this [ __ ] buddy love you got that oh
damn
dude that looks so [ __ ] up
there i'm in trouble again
make sure you put the contest oh yeah
not safe for life yeah though
where it blurs it
wait have you not seen it olivia oh
you hadn't seen it
yeah but oh no
just but just imagine you're like you
following haley mandel the the judge
from
america's got talent you're maybe like
12 years old you're new you're just a
tick tock kid and how he's dropping
[ __ ] prolapsed anuses dude
let's go y'all best be on twitter right
now checking that [ __ ] out yo uh busted
[ __ ] uh just gave 50 uh memberships
dude thank you dude busted bersey
wait i don't see it
it happened a minute ago i probably
got scrolled up already oh let me thank
busted bussie
is this the same guy
though
dude it's our saudi prince yeah
busted blissy thank you my dude
appreciate that
mm-hmm
as a gym owner i'll tell you it can't
happen but you can absolutely absolutely
poo yourself on a bad day hayley glass
said
that i believe yeah that makes more
sense i pooped my pants
a busted busy i'm not seeing the nsw tag
how come it's not showing up
there's one
there's an option to post it with the
maybe on on phones only i'll try to do
something yeah maybe trying to duty
duty
anyway so that was really exciting over
the weekend it lifted my spirits i had a
really hard long weekend but
certainly lifted my spirits that's good
um
let me play the audio i still haven't
done that for you guys
okay how are we thinking yeah yeah you
did friend neil you're right i did bent
over this happened yeah
is this what it related to
what are we gonna do about it newsweek
even wrote an article i think howie's
scared now because he's so scared of
controversy i texted him
because you know we're tight now yeah
i said yo bro i love the prolapse anus
howie hottest tick-tock of the year
crickets from him
and no comment no comment from howie
well he's also uploading tick tocks
though yeah so he didn't even get
punished which is interesting
that's that i didn't know
wait wait is he talking about it no no
related i would kill for that
howie mandel just traumatized an entire
generation of kids with one tick tock
is howie mandel in his sane mind right
now
that tick tock was absolutely insane i'm
just wow
yeah oh man are you crazy howie mandel's
tick tock is a metaphor for the entire
world raise your hand if you've been
personally victimized by hallie mandel
posting a prolapse anus on his tick tock
olivia is raising her hand
dude what the [ __ ] pros so awesome
if you guys can find any ticks-offs of
people reacting to it um
because there was i guess anybody that's
of thousands of likes
anybody that do edit it no no they were
just it was like a pts stair okay gotcha
yeah
so is it on twitter uh
i think he's still sure is oh it's up on
twitter okay
let me read some comments on twitter
i just stopped posting oh you got the
warning up
yeah yep it says don't watch these
videos
there you go
and there it is utter carelessness of
the twitter organization someone said
not the mandusky
oh that's exciting man it's a good good
weekend for that
so that happened that was exciting
um
you know i think we got to issue a
correction here
uh we made a reporting here
about machine gun kelly
his guitar now this is his like
guitarist confirmed yes
and and and like
sophie lloyd it's a it's a woman guitar
player
and so you
you can tell how can you tell just from
her
her bio yeah her bio she's verified
account she has almost
like 700k videos of her on stage with
okay wow
but also to clarify we did we did
correct ourselves on air
about it
well i feel this is good context because
you got dragged for this [ __ ] pretty
hard
and um
who who is she in this photo do you know
i'm guessing in the middle this girl
okay
so you know what man here i gotta i
gotta give it up where i gotta give it
up
we give the guy a lot of [ __ ] and so
it's only fair that we uh
be honest when we get other information
she said hi big fan of the podcast thank
you
sophie love you appreciate you
i'm machine and kelly's guitarist just
an update on the wave pool incident he
didn't get it shut down the wave pool
broke so no one could go in so we went
to ride some slides we came back and it
was running again so the band and his
daughter went in
kel's
didn't even come in as he didn't feel
comfortable and wanted to keep to
himself we actually got the wave pool to
go on for everyone at the park for 15
minutes longer
so it turns out
that they were a benefactor they were
the benefit they were the the champions
of the um they saved the way
and so you know wow flip the script
shout out to mgk mdk legend so i don't
know
you know so thank you sophie
and uh maybe machine gun kelly's maybe
we're bffs now i don't know
i gotta i watched him to the bucket with
mike and jeff
i watched his hulu documentary i watched
half of it i gotta say my opinion has
changed on mgk no yeah like i'm coming
out public saying that
that makes so much sense now that you
told me you watched the documentary
what's wrong with that
go ahead ab
because when i was he said it jokingly
he wasn't serious but i was trying to
comfort him last week about the whole
situation of him getting [ __ ] on reddit
he goes what can i say man i'm like mgk
yeah dude you get [ __ ]
how are you like you're like mgk maybe
you should how how are you like mgm
because people are giving me [ __ ] online
but i'm still selling out shows so it's
like
how many seats do you all right where
are you your latest show uh viper room
in august sold out it's like 270. oh
[ __ ] yeah actually a lot yeah you are
like mgk doing mgk numbers dude you're
selling out 300 seats that's epic bro
yeah so
are you getting paid for that [ __ ] yet
uh the day of the show but i always
split it with my band that's good yeah
so zach the chat is pointing out that
remember he's
got all those
so those predatory remarks aside
oh that's a big ad you might you just
said i'm like mgk maybe just clarify
what not in that sense but in the sense
of getting a bunch of hate but people
are still coming to your show but still
being arrested that's just that feels
like it's not that like that's not
enough similarity to say you're like mgk
in this scenario i'm like mgk okay
some people are saying you're much
better than mgk oh wow well thank you
yeah
yeah don't lower yourself yeah level
um i saw the in the documentary i mean
i was watching it for like it's so bad
it's good kind of thing because i had
nothing else to watch
it was i don't know yeah
i feel bad even to say anything bad
about him now that he no he's a friend
of the show but
[Laughter]
i didn't i wouldn't say
it's it's pretty corny bro i don't know
he's he's very dramatic he needs to like
i don't know
he takes himself too seriously that's my
problem with him i will say his vocal
fry was pretty gnarly in that
documentary it was tremendously bad
but apparently he's actually really way
more successful than i thought i mean
dude he's like spelling out the garden
yeah yeah and like his punk [ __ ] that
everyone makes fun of there's like a
hell of people there to see him
so i don't know he's got fans people
[ __ ] with the mgk
it's probably all sophie's badass guitar
playing though right that carries the
whole band that's right fan to the show
sophie lloyd everybody
dreads
she does shreds
she's like
very talented guitars absolutely shreds
okay maybe you guys could collab zach
i'd love that
she probably won't even notice she's
with another artist because you know
mgk's guys are so simple i think she's
back with mgk yeah exactly
machine gunzeli oh there you go machine
gun zilli
machine gun zilli zonk
i love that collab of the century dude
love that for you
um
all right there's two more things i want
to watch at the top of the show and then
we'll do our ace fest
uh
coverage which i know everyone's excited
about myself included
now we talked about this guy gideon
who
he got into this whole spat with pokeman
what happened with him it was like
oh yeah he
he got banned for being like a total
chauvinist dick
and then they made up he had a whole
like redemption arc with her where yeah
they they made up and they got friendly
and i think they did a stream together
and he kind of regained a lot of the
goodwill that he had lost and then uh
well
i think he's still popular i don't think
his fans care about this he has got that
aiden ross kind of like yeah oh yeah
yeah i mean but i thought it was nice at
least the way he apologized to pokemon
because most people just wouldn't do
that and i thought it was nice
regardless
it's funny i saw this video on tick tock
and
i didn't realize it was the same guy
hassan also had a beef with this guy
because he went this is the guy i think
who went to the most racist town in
america
yeah oh then his son was like
right hassan was just like i don't know
what people expect that you're just
gonna go walk around and people are just
going to be screaming racial slurs at
you that's not how it works right right
bad stuff to happen to black people i'm
pretty sure that's what that sounds like
that was about yes yeah so somehow they
spun it into hassan as a racist
and just to be clear this video was from
last year but i just
oh it's not even new no it's not it's
not new
the way it was posted on reddit
initially it looked like it was new but
looking more into it as last year
so was that before the redemption arc
that changes everything yeah this
changes everything yeah
well we're here let's just watch it
uh he i've seen this and i didn't know
was him and i mean it's such such a dick
it's just not even funny i mean i i
don't know what to say i guess kids i
don't know but watch this
oh your computer's frozen apparently uh
oh
um
[Music]
we are troubleshooting my computer
[Music]
so let's do a poll uh while dan tries to
fix this
on ace fest
last before we went we did a poll we
said
do you think it's going to be a total
disaster
it's going to be like mid
or it's going to be amazing is that
right is that fair those three
categories or do we need more
do we need more options
[Music]
so let's do a pull
out
okay never mind on the pole thank you
dan has to do the pull
we'll do the pull before the segment
[Applause]
anyway let's play you you see it dude
all right thank you what happened you
got the shirt on you got to go oh damn
for real like so i decided right now on
or out
well what's what's the deal on no i'm
just saying like what's that what's what
like the dance moves you're doing like
you're trying to hit the wall or out
by the way he starts filming now but or
it starts now i'm pretty sure
they've been arguing for a while based
on how that started he's like you got to
get in or out bro like i make you know
12 an hour i'm not trying to [ __ ]
deal with your ass no yeah yeah you see
how she asks was like polite but like
you came in here like trying to like hit
the charlie demilita on me
it's all good ain't trying to put it on
he like looked the other way it's kind
of like suss unless you roll that way
yeah you want that one homosexual
damn you're not gonna dummy up
i don't like the way you're looking at
me
yo andrew
imma catch you
later who the [ __ ] goes to best buy
without a shirt andrew hey
i can't [ __ ] stand dudes like that
bro you know what like what one coming
in here with an army of people just
without shirts on [ __ ] man i'm like a
lie andrew pissed me off like bro you
came up to me like hey man you got to
put on the shirt real quick i've been
like yeah it's cool my bro came up to me
like oh
hey what's up with your boy andrew
my brother was trying to hit the wall on
me like kind of felt violated
andrew yesterday
you discriminated me
you did not let me take off my shirt
boys uncircumcised
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
join us sir
can you please join us
why not it's simple
it's simple
free the nipple bring a nipple
it's simple the nipple it's simple free
the nipple i think i'll work here it's
done boys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know she was kind of [ __ ] up
to target that guy
yeah he's just trying to be a good
employee yeah making minimum wage
probably you're just trying to be a good
employee and you all had to [ __ ] with
them like that and call them out by name
you know
i don't know
also it's like bro i don't know if you
know this but
best spy is not the only place you can't
go in without a shirt
right
pretty sure that's everywhere
and he has a lab mic on him he has
someone following him with a camera
clearly they know
he's there to [ __ ] around
was this live streamed on twitch or was
this like a video he made i'm trying to
find an original video is deleted
oh he bailed on it yeah
i appreciate the execution of it you
know
but
the the
you know the recipient of it was not
that was just not it
you know
so that's gideon i think um
kind of a kind of a douche kind of a
dick it's not funny but
this was pre-redemption pre-redemption
arc again yeah you know yeah it's true
he has redeemed himself
he's redeemed
yeah now he's just running interference
for the kkk
much much more minor than yeah he's like
bro i went and met the leader of the kkk
he's actually a really good guy he
didn't shoot me immediately i wasn't
offended at all
he's like leader of the kkk do i have a
right to exist he's like no
go back to africa
respectfully he was very nice to me very
respectful
unlike andrew
douche
right that guy you're doing a little
shimmy right right
so that's one at the top the other one
this is one i found on tick tock
oh it was so good i used to own this and
there's been a lot of elon hate on this
podcast recently
and uh i just absolutely love this tick
tock
um
i'll let you enjoy it for yourself here
i used to own this tesla up here i
bought it in 2020 for about 37 000.
i drove it for about six months then i
decided to sell it because i saw how
tesla stock was going crazy at the time
i sold it and i bought tesla stock at
900
now the tesla stock is trading at about
seven hundred dollars
and the car that i sold for thirty four
thousand
is now worth about fifty thousand and
i'll start driving a honda civic now
i used to own this that's awesome
it's true because the the
uh used car market is so nuts right now
it's insane yes that's crazy bro
love that because i remember at the time
there was a meme like dude why if you
bought tesla stock instead of a tesla
you'd be rich
just love that
turns out you shouldn't get financial
advice from memes on tick tock no
oops but shout out to the legend i like
that he's upfront about it he's funny
there you have it guys yep um so uh
we're at 35 so i think we should do our
ad and then maybe we can sounds great
one other thing real fast
jeff weddick says uh or your best friend
my bestie
i think he messaged me and he was like
yo what's with um
mike being your best you know and i said
nah i took it back you're my bestie
he said did he really yeah he did
this was after the thing he said yo bro
i deleted twitter
don't please don't replace me with mike
swear to god oh that's so funny
and i said friendship with mike is
cancelled and he hearted it
so it's all good we're back all right
well that's good yeah
love this year
we could fight about you saying that i
got beef with ethan from h3 i don't have
beef with him i said had maybe i
actually didn't i completely just made
that up
and i side with him whatever he does and
i'm like what the [ __ ] we just no i
thought you
yeah i know but i'm not beefing with
anybody no no no tana
should start her completely missing
everything
she's so mistaken wait i wanted the
whole clip because in the whole clip she
says she's scared of me
she's scared of you she says she's
scared of me
well maybe i saw it on instagram it was
on it was on reddit or read it yeah pop
that up
she says she's scared of me because i'll
i'm a
crazy i'm just
nuts
i'm a lunatic
did the joker baby
yeah just for context she went on
bradley martin's podcast oh that guy
hates well he could fight about it i get
why bradley hates me yeah that i get
let's try this saying that i got beef
with ethan from h3 i don't have beef
with him i said had maybe i actually
didn't i completely just made that
upside down
and i side with him whatever he does and
i'm like what the [ __ ] we just with you
yeah i know but i'm not beefing with
anybody look to be fair i thought you
were i'm really happy that beef is
squash but to be fair you're focusing on
the wrong part of my sentiment it was
more so that whoever you have beef with
i ride with you yeah and i ride you stop
catching him
i'm like why was i gaslighting him and
he was like
no you're right you're right am i being
gaslighted no you had my back that's
dope but then bradley was just like yeah
[ __ ] that you got to have a plan for
ethan if you want to debate something
you want you want to get to the bottom
of something
you got to massage that guy you got to
really take your time you got to you
know yeah i don't know how much
massaging you did about me jeff
yeah
but everybody remembers how gracefully
he handled the whole situation so no no
no stop dan we're best friends i'm
saying he handled it with poison grace
he did yeah
that's why i'm sorry are you gonna have
uh an actual point that you're trying to
make you can't just be like [ __ ] him
because he lives up fight with him i
would never fight with him he's scared
just funny
he's kind of right
i don't do it consciously but he's kind
of right i do live for this [ __ ] i mean
i'm not you know what i mean i mean come
on he's kind of right you're trying to
make he can't just be like [ __ ] him
because i'm like
with him i would never fight with him he
scares me but i think it's because i've
done it's not like portnoy like i've
done too much wrong so it's like i don't
like to fight with people like that
because they're just gonna win like you
know what i mean they're just gonna come
at my neck for all the actual
wrongdoings i've done and i'm gonna be
like you suck and then it's gonna be
like really embarrassing for me
yeah the same is true with me i i don't
know why tana scared me because i
invited her on
yeah and she said yes and then i think
and then she goes to me i guess probably
because she got nervous but i don't know
why they she was she's scared of me i
mean i i want to be best friends with
all these people jeff is my homie tana's
my homie i think i think you and tana
would be funny together i think we get
on i've said that famously yeah
i try i try and she's she's scared of me
so i don't know
you know who else told me that i tr i
was
trying to get mia khalifa to come on the
show and she also said she's scared of
me hmm
well i mean bummer you've been involved
oh no that is a bummer
you come to me
on the day of my
son being curled of covered
and you say you're scared of me
you ain't scared as [ __ ] wait till you
wait till you take a ride on my robot
down on the lake
i don't know
um
[Music]
listen tell them
you don't know nothing about me
you don't know anything
you think you're a wise guy
i'll teach you a little something about
tanacon
you broke my heart
you broke my heart we could have been
the best version of frenemies i know it
was you fredo
i know it was your friend though
all right get out you stop it you guys
do you guys forced me into it and then
snooze guys i didn't even know you were
zack you i did not even ask for it i
know
they fear you
don't eat them
they fear me they don't hate me they
fear me
fear is a power powerful agent
is it better to be feared or loved
i'd like to be loved but if i have to be
feared so be it
listen you might get a pie
you might get a die
my son is seven percent italian you know
what that means
i'm
i'm the father of italian children and
you look to me
for answers in these difficult times
that's true by the way my kids are seven
percent italian yola's 14 yes she is
wow
so watch it with the italia phobia
congratulations those are my brothers
yeah those are my people
i'm the father to all italians
you come to me
on this beautiful day
you come to me
and you act as if i'm not italian
my children are seven percent of dying
i make a pasta every night it's their
favorite dish
and then you pretend you pass out you
play mobile games
i'll i'll teach you how to play mobile
games
with your guts
how dare you
[Music]
i'm italian ex
that's funny
all right stop it
anyway tana why don't you tana you
should come on there's nothing to be
scared about
i'll give you something to be you want
to be scared okay enough zach kill it
stop yeah i got ads to do yeah so i
don't know why i don't know what's with
that i don't
know but there's there you go i guess
but anyway shout out to uh tana and jeff
everybody
you know what she mentioned dave pork
boy i feel like i've turned on him a bit
too towards le i like him more now let's
go where does this come from i don't
know what started watching his pizza
review you're a new me
yeah i like his pizza reviews one play
and everyone knows the rules ethan one
bite
portnoy had a base take when abortion
rights were taken he had a super base
take on abortion
do you saw that dan
yeah okay he was like
how do i do his voice it's like
he does it really good cam does really
good let's hear it cam let's hear the
pork boy
hey josh hey joshie how you doing buddy
it's bff's podcast how you doing
everybody
hey josh you got any of the tick tock
kids invite them over
invite
we'll just go around the office talking
like dave port north
but i i gotta say i've turned on the
pork boy a bit and i'm a fan
ignoring of course the allegations and i
don't even know what happened with that
stuff but
gotta say base take on abortion love
that for him
basis [ __ ] all right let's take our
sponsor and let's get to the main whole
saga here
thank you to hellofresh we love them
you know them you love them
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
skip damn those are good wait go up what
are those bruh
enchiladas
oh my god
scallops
oh god
i gotta sneeze
watermelon watermelon watermelon
watermelon it went away
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make cooking easy
fun and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one meal kit
damn what go up what are those
flautas yeah looks like it oh [ __ ]
[Music]
guys you can choose from 55 plus weekly
option featuring pre-portioned high
quality ingredients picked at peak
ripeness hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week so you can
savor the summer flavors right from home
select meals from the taste to summer
series that are sure to become
everyone's new favorite like the old bay
shrimp and sausage boil and family style
grilled steak lettuce wraps
um i love hellofresh oh and of course
who could forget
um abs world famous burrito
[Music]
and look at those the grill marks are
pretty pretty good
what'd you get those grill marks on was
it like uh one of those
skillets uh panini press oh you put them
in interesting she was getting new
details still still i'm gonna slide them
through you did it
so so did you lightly just close the lid
you didn't press did you
stay tuned for next week
yeah you could impress a burrito
here i'm gonna follow the crease of the
fold here
look at that anyway um listen i love
hello fresh the food is always bomb it's
always fresh and it's super fun if you
don't know uh if you're not a good chef
or even if you are a good chef
it's a great way to learn and to have an
easy delicious
healthy meal
it's apparently even cheaper than going
grocery shopping because you don't buy
have to buy 10 pounds of carrots
right when you just need one single
carrot you know what i mean it's
ridiculous
72 cheaper than dining out
and let's be honest it's healthier it
tastes better it's hella fresh you gotta
love it here's the best part though
um
go to hellafresh.com h3 tv 16 and use
the code h3 tv 60 for up to 16.
free emails
wow you don't even have to three free
gifts that's hellofresh.com h3tv16
use the code h316 h3 tv 16 for up to 16
free meals
america's number one meal kit it's hella
fresh thank you thank you
yes yes yes burritos in the chat
burritos in the chat y'all
yes
[Music]
they need to add you know what they need
to do we should try to do something with
hellofresh where we get a special meal
abey's burrito so people can make it at
home like legitimately how cool would
that be i mean it's everywhere i mean at
the creator clash people have burrito
signs oh i got a text wait i gotta text
alan right now
i got to text my guy i don't want to
forget we literally need to make that
happen
that would be so fun well technically
they do
make that burrito it's just the normal
no it needs to be called abe's burrito
maybe we can get the code abey's burrito
too
okay that's funny yeah use code abs
burrito i like that can we get a custom
recipe
with hellofresh
called abey's
burrito
or just
just get a custom
code called aby's
ap's
burrito there you go you guys see you
see how the sausage is made here in this
show we had nothing from you
at one point when we were training for
the creator clash and as fan was
streaming something at one point he said
something like can you guys chill out
with the burritos i can't see the rest
of my chat
i have no idea what that's super
troopers [ __ ] burrito
gods that burrito will live forever bro
it'll live
longer than you yeah you'll be dead and
gone and your burrito will live on
and that's a beautiful thing in it it's
like my child you're immortal what's in
it it's as mysterious as the origins of
the universe
all right
baby now for the part everybody's been
waiting for
ace fest hey
fast face
[Applause]
real
quick queen eela's in the chat oh what's
up elias
i live on an av burrito lunch special
diet that's it that's what i'm saying we
got to do that we got to get this
special partnership going
hi ela love you
god bless you okay donated 200
what and said sup y'all oh blessed
teddy fresh hello fresh collab with
abe's burrito wow now we're going to
talking nick thank you for the uh
donation well that's all generous 200
thank you
i mean the idea is worth even more than
that though
yeah
abs burrito
llc
would make a company just well what if
we made our own brand of frozen burritos
oh
certain event hello fresh all together
yeah yeah cut them out what do we need
them for yeah
there's a website there's a twitter page
already i don't know who runs them oh
they're appreciated yeah
babies abuse burritos
you were talking about doing a live show
later this year
should hire
a mexican food truck and have them
temporarily rebrand h3 and sell abe's
burritos at the live show we got there's
so much more we could be doing with
these burritos
this is actually a good this is a good
idea
[Music]
i like it
all right
now let's start from the top ace fest
we've been looking forward to this event
since this was announced months ago
they've promised um
disneyland meets coachella
and they were gonna put this event on in
six months and that to me just felt
insane
the economics of this event makes no
sense to me
even like super
overpriced tickets which was like 100
per ticket and you had to buy at least
three to start three to five
the economics still didn't make sense
because we figured they sold like
three thousand
like what we did some math previously it
was like
three thousand
times three
three thousand times three oh [ __ ]
that's nine nine yeah yeah and then so
and then nine
thousand
times a hundred per ticket
that's nine hundred thousand dollars now
that's a lot of money it's a good amount
of money thank you lena
that's a lot of money but like
if you're putting together disneyland
versus coachella you got to get carnival
rides you got to get employees you got
to pay the lot which is super expensive
you got to get insurance you got to
there's so much costs associated with
that i just didn't understand how they
were getting to make money from this
[ __ ]
um the whole thing has just been
so incredible and with their history
they have a long history of
dubious business practices i'll say
and so you guys saw a lot of other drama
channels there right
yeah you saw deaf noodles we ran into
deaf
uh we actually saw him right as uh
he was arriving right as we were okay
and we ran into him again uh near the
end of the day
and uh he had a whole uh saga there as
well
i don't know if you want to get into
that but
uh yeah we'll get into that for sure
and then you saw rich lux and mad cat
mad cat
cat
he was the guy who started this whole
drama with his he did some investigating
and he was doing some gum shoe work
where he hauled the venue and uh
tried to
figure out what was going on with the
whole summer of seoul fest which was the
other event that seemed to be taking
place at the same location at the same
time
that we
were speculating that maybe they were
just
white labeling and uh you know
calling it their own festival when
really they just had a corner of this
pre-existing festival so right um you
know which we did investigate as well as
you'll see in the video well so by the
way so they got kicked out they never
even let in they apparently had like
wanted posters of some of these drama
channels
um and and and uh
and those two guys were kicked out of
the venue if they didn't i don't think
they even made it so yeah when we
arrived we were in the parking lot and
we saw them being escorted to their car
by security
um so we were actually like oh boy like
are we gonna get rejected at the door
like we were really thinking okay where
we're done they they have us zeroed in
but um
but i mean spoiler alert we made it in
no problem so
um
thank you to disney bland meets
crotchella
i know who you are you're the guy that
keeps giving how do they change their
name so often
i don't know i have no i didn't even
know that was the thing it's like kind
of wild that you can even do that
um do we have the video of of um those
two guys getting kicked out because it
is interesting because
when they're getting kicked out there's
someone from ace fest that's like
talking mad [ __ ] to them too
who's like what's up y'all yeah you guys
lie and do drama that's why you don't
get in
you know what i'm saying so let's let's
roll that
give as much context here as possible
before we share our experience there
what's up
um in the meantime
me as we pulled that up
austin put out a video
telling all haters to suck a fat donut
what is a fat donut is that i know that
must be a euphemism for something
maybe something like what howie showed
maybe yeah pro left stainless yeah
here's austin so that's why i say
twitter okay so real quick for the
people that said that our festival was a
scam or that it wasn't happening you
guys can suck a bat
donut okay because it's happened so yes
ace family it is happening this saturday
it's an all-day event click the link in
our description and get your ticket to
pull up also i do find it interesting
that they kept being like it's sold out
it's sold out oh but but please please
get tickets to come
the day before
they were selling tickets at the door
too
wow yeah i think i can confidently say
that it was not sold out
was it for my first time crowded even
[Music]
you'll see in the video i mean there was
a
you'll see you'll see
no spoilers yeah no spoilers yeah but
they did clickbait as they go it's
cancelled can't believe it
yeah let's try
you guys can suck a fat donut okay
suck a fat doughnut
okay okay all right chill out austin
here's the clip of them getting kicked
out
uh mad cat stir castor cat catster
i'm not ashamed are you ashamed
you're trying to get in
oh mad catster's in the chat
oh really
did he say anything nah he's here yeah
he donated one dollar without the
comments what's up player thanks for
that dollar one dollar
let's [ __ ] oh
yeah i got dude
wait what happened
so you guys we just got kicked out of
ace fest ace mess
a smash they let in a cozy and
spill sesh and some of the others who
have also uh run stories so wow there's
a lot of drama channels there
it was seemingly like more drama
channels than families i was assuming at
one point
but um
they are not letting us in
and you can see
so i will be suing them because oh stop
it
come on you're suing them come on
i appreciate your your investigative
work but that's a bit much
uh they had a posse waiting including
their videographer matt catster said
a posse
waiting and a videographer wow
interesting yeah like when they walked
up they said that um
people
came up to them and there was a guy
behind them filming so security
approached them but they were like being
filmed
i am surprised that they were the ones
that were targeted because nobody else
was kicked out except rich lux
and mad catster and
somehow in this massive parking lot
their car was so close to ours and when
security walked them out
and they then they pulled away the
security guards just looked at all all
of us like ten adults with no kids just
standing there were you scared
we thought we were toast i thought you
guys weren't gonna make it yeah i i
really did when when i heard they got
kicked out
but um here here's the this is pretty
interesting they did not deliver on what
they promised so it's a breach of
contract so rich i don't think there's a
contract
i think in reality you just got scammed
yeah
he says i want my money back dude well
that's well that's fair yeah you should
get a refund or charge him back if you
put it on a card he also says even
dennis got in
oh yeah no death doodles got in easy
dude you definitely should get a refund
there's no question about that if he's
not refunding you then in reality you
got scammed
you know what i mean
by the way did you guys ever get
physical tickets like how did they
confirm that you bought tickets yeah we
did it ended up like going through like
eventbrite or something right
yeah it was like a month or two later i
got an email that we had tickets in
eventbrite and i was able to connect it
yeah yeah it was it was fairly recent
though it wasn't like right away at all
okay so you guys had legit tickets you
went there and they scanned them
they scanned them in damned yeah then
they gave us
wristbands oh wristbands okay
interesting
the vip had the sky so we walked up to
the ticket counter to get our tickets
they scanned my ticket they scouted your
ticket we're supposed to get wristbands
yeah i wonder we'll get our money back
but we got we got we got pulled aside
and we were told we couldn't come in uh
apparently i don't want the press there
uh cause you know commentary channels so
we got turned away so
i wonder what it is you're hiding i mean
if there if it was a solid event are
they pressed are they are they pressed
do you refer to himself as yeah he said
they don't want press there yeah i mean
rich lux i'm sorry but i don't know yeah
i don't know if i i would
the guy who the guy who spent four weeks
making videos about a video that he
misunderstood about us yeah i don't know
oh he's the one that reported that you
yeah we're making fun of [ __ ] that guy
he's a piece of [ __ ] wait wait wait wait
wait he was reporting that you made fun
of him
of no one because he didn't obviously
don't watch the video right right yeah
well the rick's lux is famous for
literally making [ __ ] up in his
headlines yeah this isn't a [ __ ] rick's
rich lux video by the way no i just
laughing that you caught himself pressed
that's that's my opinion yeah
he i saw he posted a video recently
where he was like um
ethan klein is suing trisha paytas or
something no no trisha is supposed to be
you know suing me yeah just like a week
ago i was like oh yeah cause he had some
[ __ ] random
some nobody pretending to be a
a lawyer i'm a clerk
but i was like
dude rich poor
yeah i don't know if yeah press
poor luck [ __ ] guy poor lux
if reach lux nice i like that
rich luxe reach lux that's funny
and then you know what rick's
uh
you know
reach the house whatever i love that
thing the house it's cool but you do
reach
that's all i'm saying and you did do my
boy dirty
dan being my boy of course yeah i don't
have any problem with the mad casper
madcaster's legit bro that guy's the
king we love mad caster
yeah
then there's nothing to you know if it's
supposed to be as good an event as they
say it is why aren't they letting us in
that's interesting that's right they
made us pay for parking which so they
lied about that okay
they did say parking would be free
and they were charging people ten bucks
for parking was ten bucks for parking i
remember them saying parking would be
free you guys i i don't have that
specific memory but that's like
something that they don't nobody else
remember the parking was gonna be here
yeah but i remember some confusion as
well at one point there was something on
the website that said like five dollar
ten dollar parking and i remember you
saying you were confused because it said
free parking initially
yeah i mean the advertisement for it
changed a lot over time as we'll see oh
somebody said the first person
rich lux called when he got kicked out
was keemstar well that's a that's that's
pretty that's a problem dude
we tagged you and keemstar in the same
tweet oh okay yeah okay
tagging you after you spent the last
month
you know trying to cancel you it takes a
lot of [ __ ] balls was he i i don't
follow him really i thought we were cool
and then
it's this happens a lot with like these
smaller drama channels and they're just
they're just trying to get the clicks
and the views and stuff which i get yeah
your name gets a lot of clicks
thanks bro thanks for saying that
it's nice
i don't think he's like adamantly anti
no
rich no i don't think so either but
sometimes he goes too far like
you know
to get them clicks he
does too much
like making four videos about me
that's too much yeah that is fun
and that was just like [ __ ]
that was just such [ __ ] do you feel
famous
uh yeah yeah
sure
get it off your chest we're talking
about i did i yeah yeah i know i didn't
want to get into it i don't want to be
dragged into it but i do got to say in
that situation that [ __ ] really makes me
lose faith whenever i see someone like
dan who is
all he does is defend
he's the prime example of an ally and
he's an ally
to hear all that [ __ ] that he went
through
it's [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up
dan is dan is definitely an ally i think
it's [ __ ] up too to accuse him of
being homophobic based on literally
like the biggest rich lo the biggest
reach lux of all time reach reach the
house
reach the house somebody says rich lux
rich just likes to talk [ __ ] yeah me too
that's what i'm doing yeah okay there
you go from one from one to another i
love reach lux though guys that is
strong let me be crucified with you
tonight reaching the house
crucified by who
four luck
[Music]
i didn't see him i thought that i
thought if he showed up to ace fest
wearing that i'm like okay i think i
know why they might have kicked you out
in this family event dressing up like a
clown yeah but no no he didn't wear it
he didn't he he kept the clown makeup at
home
they both look pretty casual i'm
surprised they even spotted them
but i do wonder if they
zack with the clown i love that you got
your finger on that now um
i'm surprised they spotted them they
really must have had it out for these
guys in particular they must have been
like don't let these [ __ ] in
specifically yeah no apparently i think
they were like the only thing told the
security was probably like these two
people absolutely not that's true i
gotta say security was
very relaxed otherwise yeah
like as lacks his likes could be yeah
i'm almost ian was in front of me when
we walked into a metal detector i'm like
positive at rank and they just didn't
check him oh for real
so you could have brought a weapon to
that [ __ ] i don't i mean i don't know
maybe there was something they knew
because he had a watch on they just knew
it was the watch but
it didn't worry me a little bit you
could have packed to that open carry
they did like bag check and stuff though
so
it was literally oh mad caster he said i
had nothing to do with the phone call i
don't know what's he referring to ad cat
sure
uh keemstar maybe
oh yeah no matt you're we're cool you're
you're the man dude bro we're chill dig
you you a legend dude
you know what's interesting about it is
that you know i've been doing this for
eight years right we cover
uh tati westbrook james charles jeffree
star i've gone to all their events no
issues said hi
and there's nothing to hide it's like
what's why wouldn't you want the press
there the commentary
part of youtube you know it's
interesting and so the security guard
listen bro
okay whatever i'm not
it sucks to not get
let in but i understand why they
wouldn't and the same reason if you if
he didn't let you guys in it would have
been
really sucked but i would have got it i
was like you know
what
death noodles was telling me that um he
didn't he didn't know you had to check
in at the ticket booth and get a
wristband at first so he just walked in
oh for real yeah yeah they didn't yeah
he literally
yeah no i think it is it is
i don't have a good explanation for why
they specifically were targeted and um
you know it
it is kind of odd because like they said
i mean
when we saw them getting kicked out
we thought we were cooked yeah
but
i think they probably were a little
extra i mean mad catcher with peace and
love he was the one that kind of started
the whole
thing with like the ticket sales and
everything i guess if they saw that and
they did
so mad castro was a little extra and i'm
sure rich lux knowing reach lux knowing
him he probably went all [ __ ] extra
on their ass
but i don't know who knows apparently we
were right about ace fest and soul fast
we're gonna get into cars 100 degrees
right yeah we're gonna get in the car
hold on you guys
so wait where's the part where the
camera guy was talking [ __ ] to them it's
uh right at the beginning of
rich lux's video is there a link to that
in discord
i'll send it right now
yeah that was the part i was interested
in
oh what is this rich oh you guys are
sending me the t on rich
he posted a video
about me two months ago ethan klein is
not
sorry ethan klein don't care
h3 is fake and trisha paytas
stupid asia i mean [ __ ] you dude
i'm telling you yeah
oh guys
i say don't forget we said rich actually
didn't post much about ace fest yeah i
mean that's probably true it was it was
probably madcatzer like you said
they saw those videos and damn so you
think he got he got guilt by association
i thought the problem who rich yeah yeah
i think just showing like yeah
i'm guessing so here's richard luck's
ace family kicked me out of ace fest
with mad catster here it is he's
supposed to be included the ace fest
who the [ __ ] gave you consent to use my
clip [ __ ]
after talking mad [ __ ] saying i don't
care
reach the house
so is he an enemy of the show no rich
lux do we hate rich lux though
i thought we were really asking yes yes
he's the enemy of the show sorry rich
hey guys what's up it's me and max
here
yeah time stamp me please thank you
so um
here's the time stamp this is pretty
interesting
[Music]
i'm just working on the words
yes everyone i i don't know what these
guys are media i guess
so i mean that's probably the ace family
shooters right that's interesting
wonder if they're planning a documentary
on their haters addressing it yeah
i don't know i mean why else would
somebody
be there ready to go filming it maybe
just them maybe to have like all like
proof
that
nothing crazy happened if like claims
were made
yeah and claims were made yeah
uh rich lux we just got kicked out
oh yeah uh we got one million
subscribers on youtube i wonder why
i
i
[Music]
so he's got an ace family henchman there
yeah that sure seems like what it is
it's real interesting he's like yeah why
i wonder why you got kicked out all that
[ __ ] on the internet
i just got signed out that guy with the
skull filmed us on the way in is that
right
no on the swings oh on the swings that's
awesome
oh that was that guy so you guys might
actually be featured in
the ace family triumph documentary
that'd be impossible this guy here he
was filming you cam
yeah he's remember that wait he had the
gimbal she had a gigantic game
yeah that was yeah that was the same
thing and i i may ruin that for us uh
because dan was like you know act
excited when we were on these swings and
i kind of over did it a little bit so
what did you do i was just screaming but
like i'm not like obnoxiously loud
it's in the video
somebody asked can you specifically deny
that there were subpoenas that said uh
that were served in regards to the five
percent and trisha paytas
what
i think they're joking what can you deny
that you can i deny that i subpoenaed
her no no that you were subpoenaed oh
about the five percent yes i denied it
there was five percent differences even
what a subpoena is that's like a grand
jury summons
i again i think this person was joking
okay yeah but yeah that that was one of
the things that reached lux was saying
reach the house five percent
no there's no litigation between me and
trisha guys that's crazy
you think i'd be able to shut my mouth
up about that oh yeah
anyway so um
let's just get right into it then shall
we so um you guys drove there how long
was the drive
an hour and a half
okay that's not that bad
and when you arrived and opened the door
and got out what was the was it hot as
[ __ ]
it was super hot it was it was very hot
it was like out in the wasteland like
yeah mad max [ __ ] you know like right
totally
it's just
when i got there
uh
i saw a
person that looked like they were having
a bad trip
okay like some sort of tweaking
situation
they were picking their skin um
so then i got back in my car
i think there is a lot of like drug use
out there definitely there's not a lot
else else to do there so
i get it
were you gonna say something olivia
oh i was just gonna say uh everyone was
standing together when i pulled up in
the parking lot and before i could i was
like gonna say something about the
location but i felt a giant gust of heat
all over and i just screamed like oh it
is gross olivia made the mistake of
wearing pants well
yeah
yeah i mean i was fine people like to
wear pants it was just it was pretty
gross for a minute
oh there's one other thing i wanted to
ask i i someone was live streaming there
before you guys arrived
and when i opened it immediately as i
opened it a huge tent was blown over
there was like violent wind there love
do you have that is that in the video
what happened to that no that's not in
the video oh we do have it though i sent
it to love too yeah yeah it's a rip just
save it let me i can pull it real quick
it was so crazy like i just clicked this
live stream randomly it was one guy by
himself i forget the name
what is his name a toesie a toesie and a
huge [ __ ] tent just blew over
violently i mean it could have killed
someone if they were under it it was
nuts
lover do you have it
and dan you said you're you got it right
well i'm going to our
video assets here i'm looking for it i
don't have it right now so here all
right
okay so this is basically
a little bit of it thank you uh cameron
oh
oh
oh
oh
so so that just happened
is everyone okay
i kind of wish we had the beginning of
it
it was pretty crazy
oh my god this is the tea oh
so i was like holy [ __ ] this this vessel
or this vest is nuts
so so that just happened uh is it going
okay
[Music]
oh
yeah
oh
look at this oh wow it looks like a
hurricane
[Music]
oh
my goodness oh
i was like holy crap this place is kind
of even dangerous potentially
oh you got the full clip awesome thank
you yeah just show the beginning of it
super windy
just that's when i just clicked the live
stream and watched this going down i was
like what the [ __ ] it looks like the
first thing you saw yeah immediately so
was it super windy there um to be honest
when we were there not really just
a violent wind i mean i think this was
several hours before we arrived so yeah
i think it just died down by the time we
got there it was like it was just like a
warm like windy heat right yeah yeah it
felt like when you walk into a hot car
when we stepped out right right right
i want to do a poll before we watch this
video
what do you expect happened that is fest
um
total scam at ace
fest
just [ __ ] event
like total scam
shitty damned
mid or
best day ever
is that too many options we can do four
so total scam
[ __ ] scam or just fun event i think i
don't think best day ever [ __ ]
i don't know total scam [ __ ]
it was mid
best day ever best day ever
here was our predictions going into this
we bought tickets to ace families new
scam fest
ace family scam just got a thousand
times worse
ace fest is reaching fire festival
levels of scam
ace family's newest scam is so blatant i
wonder if they had a picture of me up
and then didn't target any of you guys
you know i i actually thought that
because yeah i mean that would make
sense they wouldn't [ __ ] recognize us
like maybe a b because he led the um
uh content court that we did but that
was years ago i think they just have a
pick of me yeah they probably had a
picture
i was definitely a little worried
because of the what dan said and also
because he's doing a boxing event and we
just had the creator clash so i thought
maybe
right you might have recognized you from
that um is this ace family new scam ace
family predicts their own downfall it's
a lot let's be honest
so let's everyone do their pull let's
see let's let's i'm going to say my
expectation was that it was basically
gonna be
damned [ __ ] i don't know
yeah so you wouldn't i thought you're
you were saying it was i was somewhere
between total scam and [ __ ] yeah because
you kept saying like the economics make
no sense yeah that kind of implies
there's some sort of scam element to it
well okay what i really thought was
gonna happen is that because on the same
day there was that summer soul festival
right we really thought that they were
just gonna have a booth there right
and they were just up charging like a
five dollar ticket for 100 bucks right
you guys can suck a fat donut okay but
now you guys can see total scam is 25
[ __ ] is 34 mid 35 best day ever five
percent five percent fiber sand
i'm suing ethan for the five percent
well without further ado
um
let's roll
our experience at ace fest all right
what's up we're here in beautiful
palmdale california
and we're here for the ace festival
so uh as we walked up uh we saw a number
of people getting kicked out uh you know
some other commentary channel what the
[ __ ] weren't you wait wait wait zach
i thought you weren't coming what's up
guys what the [ __ ] are you doing here oh
i'm going to the summer at seoul
festival they're at christopher cross
tribute bands playing if you're going to
summer soul do you feel like that's a
little too many buttons i can go lower
dude i'mma want to turn into a red
lobster v my guy anyways it was great
seeing you guys you know we'll miss you
great seeing you guys
treating us like we're like fans that
you ran into or something i mean
kind of impeding on my
soul right now i got to give it to you
though you're looking very soulful you
do yeah i mean yeah you know kangal
shades yeah khaki shorts you know you
got it you got it stole fargos [ __ ] yeah
dude did you buy the hat for the event
or did you have that like ready to go i
feel like that's a subjective question
man
no when did the hat become his you know
what i mean but yeah it was really great
you know running into you guys well if
you decide you want to like actually
like do your job
maybe come over to the ace fest i mean i
mean if we get kicked out of ace fest
i'm definitely going to join you at the
summer soldier okay okay we gotta like
do our job like
get go go get my summer solstice
[Music]
that was weird
um so yeah we're here at days fest um
you know
there was a lot of promises made we're
gonna see if those promises were kept uh
it was advertised as coachella meets
disneyland which um
well
i mean coachella is in the desert
so they got that part and it's always
hot there so far looking at the
inflatable
waving guys in the front i feel like
this is
ninth wonder of the world potential live
music one of the things that they
promised yeah i'm not well let me
correct you there sam i don't believe
live music was ever promised live
performances were promised and
performance
as you'll note is a fairly vague word
that could mean anything from a full
band to
juggler i don't know so but we're really
here because we are
big ace heads yeah
we got all of the merch the the drip
oh look at that
boom i got nothing oh yeah
oh well what the hell
i got an ace family shirt yeah for sure
so it would really would be criminal to
kick us out because we are just
we
are big fans are ace yeah
[Music]
uh before you guys head in um
i saw they promised that there was gonna
be live
uh there's gonna be uh animals there
was there livestock there
i saw some pigeons
there was pigeons there were definitely
they're probably not
with ace fest i didn't see
i didn't get a close enough people to
pet the pigeons
i tried oh rich lux is in the chat they
flew away he says i'm shook can't
believe it they did not let me in i
guess he didn't see the first part
well guess what hey rich
and welcome to the show
don't rewind buddy yeah don't go back
you're not about to get kicked out of
another thing oh
oops
oh did you ban him no wait did you ban
him dan no
oh you wouldn't do that would you i
would never wait did you yeah i banned
him oh my god damn
oh the goat
and dan that's too much damn too much i
should unban him
i mean coming in well too bad i'm kind
of helping him out in a way because no i
no don't squelch him i want to hear if
he has first of all very funny idea but
i want to hear if he has anything to say
um i'll see if i can figure out how to
undo him oh god
we're trying to figure out how to unban
you
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
rachel if you want to say anything you
can go through mad catcher he's not
banned we let him send your messages to
mad and stay mad oh my god dan
excuse me so there was no livestock so
that was a lie
was there any live music
i know dan you made a point about
performances versus music but was there
music there was
uh no there was djs
there was just no not even one in there
yeah there was djs
more than one dj no not just inside
outside as well oh really yeah i was
looking at their turntables there was
two djs
at least i thought these fire
three djs that's insane possibly four
nine djs what whoa
was all djs and drama channels
all right go ahead and roll it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i felt like i was going too far i was
gripping it because i was sliding up
you know
i'm gonna say it i'm having fun i'm kind
of having a good time dude i'm gonna say
this [ __ ] rule it's good it does it's
kind of lit i love it let's do some more
rides here
fun
yeah
[Music]
bye
no one's even in here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i was wrong
it's like nothing to do
christopher crossball
i give up
i'm just really [ __ ] upset man
just wanted to come get my soul on
[ __ ] ace best why does it have to be
so fun
[Music]
i'm having like a great night i'm having
a really good time i gotta be honest
he's pressed
hey
yeah
oh hey what's up zack how's it going
uh it's going really good actually we're
having a great time how's the soil
festival yeah festival
it's not great
not great
can can i come over there yeah i thought
the sauna was so fest was gonna be so
funny
christopher cross failed dude i've had
my fun here i want to come to ace fest
are you ace gang
because we are dude i [ __ ] with austin
man he's my homie i'm hype as [ __ ] you
guys suck let me in your outfit's kind
of giving predator you don't want your
outfits kind of moving
yeah i'll tell you what zach you can
come over but you gotta button up that
shirt never
you can die
i'm already severely sunburned so the
lobster v has already taken effect
so i'll i'll button up about seven
people have told us that there's a hole
in the fence over there oh really yeah
yeah just kind of sneak in i
kind of
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo
i win this is awesome i love the aceved
i love aids the view of palmdale is
fantastic up there
beautiful today
[Music]
he's bumping cam
maybe he's the one bumping cam now
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like david dover excavator dude
dude
puzzle
i love you guys
[Music]
oh did you capture all that
whoa
sam's been waiting in line for like an
hour at least
and that's
all right so now we're going up to the
the meet and greet so but it turns out
the fest ace fest was [ __ ] awesome
you guys had a great time it was it was
a legit it was a blast it
turns out
that uh a giant carnival with a bunch of
rides that are all free and a bunch of
games no line with almost no one there
dude it was like a really [ __ ] good
time it was a good
day so by the way someone asked so um
lily perez asked did you all have to pay
for activities at games or were they
separate or included in ticket price all
included all included the games were
free isn't that a great you could play
the carnival games and they had prizes
yeah were prizes and you could just keep
playing as much as you wanted and the
rides had no lines no lines and they
were free and they looked fun as [ __ ]
dude that first one were spinning fast
like no no bro
you i really thought i was gonna die
that was so crazy
i very often
go on roller coasters i love that was
the scariest thing i've ever done they
would like they slowly brought us upside
down and we only had this thing and they
brought us all the way to the top and we
they just had us hanging there and i
thought i was gonna fall out head first
didn't you olivia didn't you lose
something out of your pocket too i
thought i thought that i had dropped
something olivia had no reservations
about it she's just like i'm going for
it yeah i really i made that choice
quick and then on the swing ride
apparently ab was swinging wildly you
were able to kick the person in front of
you
dan was sitting behind me i thought he
was [ __ ] with me and then like when i
was like i was going like this i'm like
oh that dan wouldn't be doing that like
no because that i was starting to
remember the standard spacing
you know
i wouldn't have been able to reach out
and kick you no you're you just got the
cursed chair and it started like
swinging wildly like in a circle
you were slamming into me and then
slamming
kind of pulled my whole body forward
like this
were you scared i was i was i was scared
definitely you could tell the guy with
the controls when whenever we would pass
him i saw he was just smiling
he like loved that we were so scared
i had i had fun but i'm a little sour
about the summer soul dude yeah and then
so what's funny is
the summer of soulfest which we thought
they were going to be ripping from
actually sucked completely
one of the most the most pathetic yeah
i've ever seen yeah tell me about summer
of soul zach um well
on the ad it was supposed to be like
live music
and then like a
they put it a low rider competition
but there were like three cars in the
parking lot oh my gosh
and like
no one was in the food trucks the food
trucks were unoccupied they were
unoccupied
it was just a weird vibe and there were
we saw other tweakers in there oh [ __ ]
it was hot
and christopher cross tribute bailed
was there free water there
uh no no yeah so at the ace fest they
had free water stations free water
throughout the park yeah
to sit down under like shade to eat a
bunch of tables wait you said that
bubble water i mean like bubbler
out of like a filtered bubbler i meant
that a bubble water no bubble water
bubbles it was still it was tap
so in the end
they pulled it off and i have to say
it's super impressive to me
that they actually f i still don't
understand the economics i don't know
how much money dan has done donned his
ace family hat
i got mine and this was the most uh
shocking outcome
the guys were telling me i was with
theodore sick with covid and then the
guys they were sending me updates in the
in our group chat of just how much fun
they were having it was so interesting
to see it go down yeah i also have to
say sam and i we were at the glitter
tattoo station and we talked to one of
the girls who worked there was it free
uh yeah
oh [ __ ]
she said that that small business has
like consistently been employed by the
ace family dude which was
i gotta say that's cool and like their
boss had met catherine and everything
so here's what i'm thinking
um
someone's saying it was low-key a scam
though i don't actually think it was a
scam at all was it i don't think so i
mean
promises made promises cab well
we should we should do a full assessment
at the end of the video because there is
still a few details to be included but i
would say
mixed
mixed bag it wasn't a scam though i mean
scam is probably too far but i mean they
did
was it was it disneyland meets coachella
absolutely not
were there live performers
i guess if you count the dj's as that i
guess they're performing yeah yeah i
mean i feel like live performance
sort of indicates to people like a band
or something like that but whatever and
then they did say uh wild animals and
and to yeah honest
and to be honest about that i'm kind of
glad there wasn't me too animals and
that he oh my god
horrible yeah that's a good point yeah
yeah those poor animals i feel so
validated
shout out to the chat why do you feel
validated because i predicted it
you predicted it would be a
banger no no i said i it would work out
no one could explain how but it'll work
i'll be fine
and everybody's like abusive
i don't know what the hell they were
saying but you've been holding on to
that i have yeah very satisfied i mean
austin are actually boys now so
oh yeah well that's coming up um so
anyway um listen but again it was 500
bucks for you guys all to go there's a
hundred dollars
it's a very expensive uh county carnival
but guys essentially what it was get
this
right i guess that is the point serious
that's a serious
we paid a hundred dollars for the vip
tickets because we are very important
people um
how much were just like the regular
tickets like if you showed up at the day
i thought it was a hundred bucks 120
yeah i think 120. that's what we paid
for the vip so the regular tickets cam
said the normal ticket to get in was
120.
we paid i think 4.99 right sam
for five tickets yeah she's saying yeah
right for the five ticket package that
was the vip package right what i'm
saying
i thought it was 100 bucks for one
ticket they sold one ticket 100 bucks
whatever i guess i'm just asking if
there was like a lower tier ticket that
didn't i don't think the vip uh meet and
greet experience or whatever there were
singles that i think were like 120 or
something like that yeah
that were not vip no they were more
expensive
dude it was not it was 100 bucks per
ticket was the cheapest yeah i think so
and then there was something for oh yeah
i think you're right and i think those
were sold out um
excuse me by the time i checked again
then there was a 299 that was three
tickets or well the funny thing about
this disney versus coachella thing is
like once again near disneyland there's
this theme park called um adventure land
which is like 25
per ticket and it's like
that
times four
so obviously but like if you're a fan of
ace family
well that was what i was gonna try and
say is the vip ticket got you the meet
and greet so if you're a fan
like how do you judge
the dollar value of getting to meet
somebody that you're a fan of you know
that plus the carnival i will also say
that if you go to adventureland you have
to pay for the r the carnival rides or
the carnival games i will say it was
kind of trippy to be doing like typical
carnival stuff you know throw a ring or
top normally you have to dole out these
tickets and you can just do it once and
then you got to keep buying tickets we
would just miss the thing and go get hey
give it that no one was there that's
awesome we were just playing the games
you could do it as long as you wanted so
did you guys all win or was it even
impossible to win that [ __ ] for free ian
won he won that the thing that ian's
wearing right now yeah
like a hoodie uh tote bag but i do need
to say he didn't need a second try and
he hit that on his first try thanks bro
is that right what game was that on
that's yeah the basketball basketball
it's in the start of the video too but
also it was really nice there was a
bunch of families there
like walking around and that's primarily
what it was yeah looking happy we were
that's what we realized shortly after
getting there
because we had like made jokes like you
kept saying like oh man this is like a
predator's paradise or whatever uh going
to the like we're walking around like
we're the [ __ ] weirdos yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like we're the people without kids deaf
noodles was the weird guy by himself
exactly yeah
so but it was families happily having
fun they said
and the food the food was great all the
food i had is reasonably priced oh yeah
you guys said the food trucks were off
the road they were like actually really
good food trucks there yeah that pretzel
place was good yeah i do also want to
say
to thank um um
uh dan king [ __ ] dan
for a hundred gifted subs oh my god out
of control thank you bro this is
[Applause]
whoever you are reach out we gotta talk
you gotta talk he has to be an oiler i
think
an oiler he might be a juicer
do you think
right right or he just steals credit
cards and then they charge back sure
sure
so somebody chat asked if there was free
food i don't think that was ever
advertised no no the food was not free
yeah but it was like regular price it
wasn't overpriced yeah it was now i have
to say uh it was 120 at the door to get
in not vip
attosi
said that he had to pay for water at the
water station
no there's no no no love that's that
where did you see that love that he had
to pay for water oh
so
what you guys saw contradicts that at
least as far as when you guys went to
get water there was no
there were just multiple it was a water
jug with cups it was water coolers and
there was the cups and it was and they
were there was a dude there that all day
was coming and pouring ice into it you
would like take off the jug and pour a
big bag of ice water so it was ice water
yep i hit that multiple times yeah i
kept hitting it it was full there wasn't
a couple there were missed there were
misters too in some parts
i got to say the ice is a nice touch
they could have just served your ass hot
water i thought so too i thought so too
so okay let's so obviously it's
expensive right
um but let's let's continue then um
someone said they advertise free food i
don't think so
i don't ever i mean
if you
actually know that for a fact send it to
us because i mean that would be that
would be another check mark in the in
the scam column
right advertise free food but i i don't
i don't think i ever saw that
but
could be wrong about that
so anyway let's continue on to the um
another
uh let's continue on to the meet and
greet part which i think you guys will
notice
looks a lot like a fema emergency
center
it's giving me a theme of emergency vibe
yeah yeah but anyway here it is check it
out next part two sam's been waiting in
line for like an hour at least
and that's what
this is the end of the line
the ace family is taking the time meet
people very
kings legends kings and queens alert
excuse me are you sam from h3 uh you
guys you made it far
you're like still at the end
something just happened like 10 minutes
ago and everyone was like screaming and
cheering and people were like putting
pulling their phones out i don't know
zack lewis walked by oh that's probably
what it was all these drama channels are
trying to paint this as astral world
it's it's seven o'clock you'd assume
they would start being like hey that's
great nice to meet you leave not the ace
they want to know your origin story
where you're born
how you grew up
childhood friends
what you had for lunch they want to know
all of them
that's the type of experience you're
going to get care about
i'm so excited to tell them we're here
with dennis the legend deaf noodles
chef how you doing
we need to know how is your ace
experience it's been absolutely amazing
the greatest experience in my life they
gave me a scarf
it's a 100 degrees outside and i got a
scarf oh
it's good it's very quiet
is that gucci gucci yeah oh wow and
you're waiting to meet the legends and
stuff i this is like the greatest moment
of my life this is going to be the apex
of everything it's it's converging to
this moment so i can't wait for your
official ace man official ace fan fan
i'm
literally a part of the cult
a spam for life
for life let's go
we're so close
getting kind of nervous i'm very nervous
butterflies
i'm more nervous than walking into the
greater class
[Music]
just want to say the somehow is still
great we have so much fun it's a really
good event so thank you so much thank
you for coming yeah thanks guys
okay good great perfect
how'd it go
great did you meet the legends
everything i dreamed of i got this
autograph
let's get this i got to sell this bad
boy before i leave
[Laughter]
honestly
nicest people i've ever met
i'm down with the fan mail like for real
fan for live footage
let's go
all right all right all right i need
some rhythm
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys how are we feeling
this is the time of my life
beautiful sunset
it's the time of my life
that was not a scam in reality
we got a good money's worth for our
ticket crisis today reality
you got fam
in reality i had a great time
[Music]
there you have it guys uh the most
unexpected
outcome what a twist
in reality you got famed as ian said
that's right and first of all i think
you guys all did such a great job thank
you guys all for going out there so cool
and i'll say um you know i'm actually
glad you guys had fun i it was nice that
you guys went out there and had a good
time
so so um
thank you for dinner by the way let me
just say that oh and ethan covered
dinner yeah right yeah everyone got
enjoyed red lobster lobster how was the
meal by the way i've never been there
there was like almost nothing for
meal thing it's like a little bit of
everything how much was the bill
how much does red lobster cost don't
don't worry about it i wouldn't don't
don't look at the credit i want to know
how much it was tell me how much
i ordered before you said before uh yeah
actually i just curious how much does
red lobster cost it was a hundred and
eleven dollars for all of us to eat
that's nothing are you [ __ ] kidding
me
i was just i was razzing what the hell
that's nuts well it's because he's not
lying we
we weren't expecting you to pay for it
and then you asked if we needed to be
reimbursed for anything i was like well
we're at dinner right now you want to
cover dinner and you were like yeah of
course put it on the card so
if we had known that before we might
have gone a little bit more all out well
that 111 bucks for like what five people
yeah yeah pretty good [ __ ] red
lobster let's go
that's hella cheap
um well anyway good job everybody that
was awesome
so what was a better deal red lobster or
ace fest
um
probably red lobster red law from being
honest yeah that sounds good i mean they
had the biscuits so let me ask you this
dan you were hesitant to say i said i
don't think you guys were scammed at all
are you why were you hesitant to
well because they promised things for
the event that weren't there i mean
you know we got to be balanced here and
so they did i i know they up kept
updating the
flyer right like here's the uh yeah i
have it right here uh mod mega awesome
sent it to me a moment ago but somebody
had posted this to the sub but yeah
seeing it like
the things slowly get removed i mean we
bought when it was this or i'm sorry
so wait when they added stuff and then
subtracted it so wait they say free
rides free games free prizes free
performances so that one was actually
true if you say djs is performances
which and technically i think that would
make sense guys can suck a fat donut
a little misleading but it works then
they go free rides free games free
prizes
access to free wildlife
yeah that
access to free i think it says park
wildlife park which is strange
yeah there was nothing of the sort so
you know if you want to call that a scam
that that's definitely and then the
final uh one is free rides free games
free prizes yeah which all of those
all those did exist so you know they
delivered on three out of the five uh
bullet points here i don't think it was
a scam i don't i don't think so i mean
it was misleading it's false advertising
here a little bit yeah but also it's for
their fan base like you said like it's
different if you're a fan you i feel
like you're getting more than your money
that's the thing and like i said i mean
their fans were there
they seem to be having good times their
fans by the way are exactly what i
thought they were it was a lot
of
young families like not just the kids
being young but like the parents young
you know people that had kids in like
their early to mid 20s and now their
kids are i guess around the age that the
ace families kids are or whatever and
you know it's definitely not my scene
but i guess they they find them
relatable or you know they they're
they're like us but but glamorous you
know but they have money and they aspire
to be like them whether or not that's a
good thing or not so that's that's who
likes them that's who was there
and uh yeah i mean for an event for kids
it it was it was fine it was fine i
would have vote like based on our poll
our four ratings there of scam [ __ ]
mid or
best time of our life
it was mid no it was definitely the best
time of your life
and i was okay that's mine did you guys
see how you ended that video well we
were hamming it up no no no we did have
a good time i don't want to say any
specific channel names but a lot of
people are completely full of [ __ ] i'll
just say that a lot of the pictures
taken were strategically taken
they were
a lot of the commentary channels came
super early before anyone else got there
they were showing empty like it's empty
it's deserted right and i could have
taken
similar pictures but it'd have to be
intentional what were some of the
the falsehoods that are being said on
other drama channels i haven't kept up
but just you know like i think someone
said something about water and about how
it's just empty in general you're saying
people are being charged for water that
wasn't true that it's empty that wasn't
true yeah well people really wanted to
draw this conclusion that ace fest was
going to be a total scam [ __ ] show i
mean we literally went there with that
narrative yeah yeah yep we had to change
it up halfway through yeah we were
walking around and we were like
we started to have a conference not on
camera we kind of recreate it on camera
but that
you know
a less dramatized version of what you
saw in that video basically happened
where i think olivia was the one to
break the ice she was like guys
i'm kind of having a good time i started
taking um a forgiveness sympathy vlog so
i was like i don't know if i can stand
by whatever narrative we're gonna do
because there you go i mean my goodness
and and again i don't even under i don't
know how much money they made from this
because that looked it looked expensive
right to put all that there yeah i saw
somebody make a donation a little bit
ago i i don't we'll have to look into
this but apparently somebody did some
digging and
they're claiming that they their
expenses were 25 grand impossible which
to me seems exceptionally low i don't
know that's impossible i i i kind of
agree uh i don't know
what investigation was done so i mean
maybe we can look into it but that that
seems like a stretch i feel like the
expenses had to be more than 20.
hundreds of thousands there's no [ __ ]
way
do you know how much of work it is just
to bring those rides out and assemble
them
like that's insane right yeah and
generally with those carnivals you know
um
when they're charging for the games and
everything you can get them for very
cheap or even for free because they just
take they make their money by the
carnival game
exactly but because it was free and all
the rides were free and everything they
had to have paid them to be there so you
know well someone said to me for my city
carnival looks just like that yeah no i
agree but yeah it was insane small town
fair vibes they they did it imagine your
city carnival but ethan and eel are
there that's you know what i mean that's
what it's for like you would definitely
pay that most people someone said
insurance liability had to be at least
25k hundred percent right yeah huge
liability insurance i'm just saying guys
that that that's crazy event to put on
man
i mean i've put on stuff like that on a
much smaller scale it's super [ __ ]
expensive dude yeah
um but there you have it you know
calculation that they had a connect with
that venue which would kind of what
venue like the place in lancaster or
palmdale or whatever
they are they did it because it's cheap
i mean i agree but maybe it was even
extra cheap i mean that would explain
because like why do it in [ __ ]
palmdale because it's cheap as [ __ ] yeah
for sure but
you can't as [ __ ] means free or like
barely anything because if you tried to
do that
if you got a lot that big anywhere
closer to la than [ __ ] lancaster it
would cost like you know a hundred
thousand dollars yeah usually i will say
next year though
summer soul better step up their game
man i don't think there's gonna be a
summer solo next year
you should suck [ __ ] dude
what if austin scammed the event and the
carnival people instead of the fans oh
oh oh that's interesting well better
them than than the fans i guess i
definitely yeah i mean well let's see if
there's a lawsuit
because i hope nobody got scammed
that's a funny uh thought yeah that is
funny checks in the mail
i will say to their credit too when they
were doing the meet and greet they were
doing it for like what eight hours nine
hours and they
like gave their all to every person that
came up the same their full energy good
that's hard yeah i do not know how they
because i i've done meet and greets for
like four or five hours i don't know how
much but it is so hard man i mean just
really really really hard that's that's
actually another thing i wanted to
address too i saw online that people
were saying that people were being shoot
away from the meet and greet but they
made a big announcement saying that now
is the time last call to
get in before we shut off the meet and
greet
and everybody that was in the building
at that time got to see them that's cool
someone exciting proposal said i took a
deep dive into it and it was 15k no i'm
sorry bro but
that's just not possible you're also
being subpoenaed dude he has private it
would cost fifty thousand i'm sorry dude
it's just not possible
i'm really sorry
i just it's just not possible it was a
weird phenomenon i just felt like i was
part of the family being there and i
didn't even notice what i did when i was
like gabe austin like that dude that
[ __ ] you dabbed him up it was so
funny
this is what's so funny
so
me
sam and ian were in there taking the
photo and then we drove to the
restaurant separately and in my car was
me dan and kam and i'm explaining to
them how ian was a legend how he turned
around and he got that video and they
probably thought ian was a creep and i'm
describing it we're cracking up and then
like
as we're pointing to the to the
restaurant i'm telling dan well you know
what i don't know why the [ __ ] i went
like this to him and then dan started
dying laughing i realized oh holy [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] weird why did i
you dabbed him up like that old hole you
got like yeah my whole life
holy [ __ ] and he greeted you right oh
yeah they matched that energy random
accent [ __ ] katherine definitely thought
i wanted to turn her into a lampshade or
something oh yeah for sure wait what
why well
we walked up and ripe we had a whole
plan of how we were going to shoot it
and right before they they told sam you
got to turn your camera off no cameras
maybe i don't know why dennis def went a
few people right before us he was
running from us in line i don't know
and he had a little bit of an
interaction with them maybe that's why
they were having people shut off their
cameras
yeah maybe but
so he was like photo only
and then i was like well we need a v we
need a video
and so as we were leaving i like pulled
up my phone quick and i was like hey
catherine
and
it was so uncomfortable oh my god damn
you did good work though
that was awesome you did
in the video you see me hug ian as he
walks away it's because ian has shaky
hands like me and so he was like holding
his shoes yeah and i like i embraced him
as a shaky-handed brother yeah
like we had this like dawning
realization throughout the day that it's
like here's ian
like
a guy that looks like he's like around
30 by myself
shaking like crazy like i'm so i'm so
excited to meet you and i decked out an
ace merch i had this and the shirt and
all yeah it's like
we were the freaks yeah transformed dude
you both became different people when
you met katherine and austin yeah
did they look in person by the way did
austin look did they look good they look
good but i thought austin be taller a
little short guy huh
sam talked to catherine for a bit too oh
you chatted up catherine catherine
looked amazing really yeah like in
person she looks just like her pictures
wait did you know that she dated michael
b jordan
[ __ ] weird is that that was so crazy
we knew that i think that was
maybe mentioned in the concert i didn't
know that she dated michael b jordan
before ace before awesome what a step
down bro
she dated like sexiest man in the world
hello i'm just saying bro he won
all right hold on michael b jordan one
sexiest man of the year yeah awesome
mcbroom rocks
i'm just saying dude that's
that's crazy you gotta you gotta meet
him meet austin before you talk please
so he was just you'll understand yeah
exactly does he [ __ ]
zach in the bathroom or something
no i i went
why won't you say if he [ __ ] or not
okay he [ __ ] he [ __ ] yeah he [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] dude he [ __ ] up he was
wearing a watch that [ __ ] i'll give it
i'll give him that did he have a rollie
on no i was a diamond ap it [ __ ] he
[ __ ] he [ __ ] all right thank you
that's all i wanted to know
by the way here's one of these posters
so it says ace fest pass
that we got the vip so it says
five tickets access free autographed
poster which we got guaranteed to meet
and take pictures which happened
so now you guys get austin's next fight
for free that's really interesting sure
do i got the the piece of paper that
gives us uh i thought they'd be
streaming it there for some reason i
don't know why
but when we were getting the wristbands
at the thing they're like oh here's a
piece of paper to get 20 what was it 24
24
20 off the fight or what no no no
it is what was 20 off then
it was if it was 20 off if you want to
uh get a ticket to go see it in person
that's what it was oh you guys got a
free like streaming key it's a
pay-per-view okay so so everybody that
was there got a flyer with a qr code for
a free stream that stove thing or
whatever also what about the wedding
yeah i was just saying wedding gift i'm
crossing my fingers we left before they
did the raffle we messed up
yeah they did the raffle
after we left what kind of stuff were
they giving away none of the wrappers
were giving away access to their wedding
tennis to their wedding you guys could
have been front row oh
and access to the fight too
right right but i hope i hope they see
this and they're like oh [ __ ] somebody
actually is
telling it like it is yes ace fest was a
bop we're giving it to people straight
yep well yep we're the real article now
does this quality question any of our
other other assumptions about the ace
family um
[Music]
i mean maybe
maybe like on the level of like is it
not is austin new bestie no no no no no
no why don't we no no no no no let's
call it a wash let's just wash out no i
don't think it's a watch this is a new
start i mean i think i think the lesson
learned
is that
you know as far as putting on like a
large-scale event for their fans
um
they are
i wouldn't say like super good at it
because again you know it wasn't an
amazing event by any means but speak for
yourself
it was it was fine and it's like in the
past they did those like basketball
charity events
um
which you know that takes some
organizational skill to put on a show at
staples center or whatever so
yeah i i don't think that they're as far
as like just outright
ripping their fans off but
are they
well they did have the one like the what
was it the ace college or whatever it's
where the sound bite where he's like in
reality
you know what i would be willing to do
because of this event
scam ace academy
what i would be willing to do and i'm
just going to float this out there
if austin if they want to call in or
come on the show they'll never do that i
would love to have a candid conversation
with them about all this stuff and since
i'm like listen this event was legit
was not a scam
that maybe you all can i can speak some
truth uh in your offense to the other
accusations
i just want i would love an official
statement about how much money for
charity was raised at their basketball
event
that's one of the questions i would
definitely ask them yeah because selling
out staples center and then donating
what was it like 50 000
was it
yes they said 100 000 they gave 50.
selling out staples center and they had
super expensive food they they
definitely raised millions right so
50 000. a very very scammily yeah
exactly but
i mean
all that aside
we went to report on ace fest ace fest
was all right
there you go it was all right how about
that huh it's so unexpected
family family
family
oh we stay in austin stop one last note
that i want to say
because i actually just saw somebody say
you know
[ __ ] the whole like family channel thing
which yeah true
um
i
actually went into this thinking
probably like
the like scams aside like the grossest
part of all of this was like you're
going to do [ __ ] meet and greet with
your kids
the ace family because it was like
being presented as a meet and greet with
the ace family their kids as far as any
of us could tell were not present at the
event which good for them like
good don't don't bring your kids to meet
a bunch of strangers that would be
pretty crazy to bring kids yeah which
they didn't do anything like that it was
just austin and catherine which like
good leave leave the kids out of this
the kids used to come up and reach into
the pool and also i just want to know
real quick when a lot of people are
showing these empty pictures of the uh
fair it was because the meet and greet
went from outside to indoors
probably because it was too hot but
there was yeah there was majority of the
people were inside probably at that time
whenever that's what was pointing yeah
those videos of like you know not many
people around it was because all their
fans were lined up inside trying to get
photos with them or whatever there was a
shitload of people in there [ __ ] time
yeah
those photos were also like right when
it opened up too so yeah i don't know if
everybody piled in at that point or
anything but it was right when the event
started i mean right when we pulled in
we saw how many commentary channels were
just when we rolled up so yeah
um what was the bathroom situation like
uh
they had portrait bathrooms but also
what was it in the uh meet and greet
section there was like indoor bathrooms
there were bathroom facilities and then
there were all supportive bodies there
people saying that the kids were there
in the morning before they moved it
indoors um okay well maybe the kids were
there at some point they weren't there
when we were there so
well there you have it and and you know
a very unexpected outcome now obviously
i have to give a an honorable mention to
death noodles who
went all out he went for it he gave me
the idubbbz meeting tana kind of vibes i
mean obviously a lot less extreme let's
be free but you know shout
out dennis is like huge by the way
he's a big ass [ __ ] dude yeah he was
like 10 people ahead of us
um i'm pretty sure this is why they made
you turn off the cameras but yeah dennis
went for it he live streamed it and um
well here it is
i said how do i learn to scam as good as
you guys so he really went for it
he didn't come
here
[Music]
[Music]
did you guys see this go down what
happened literally we i was watching him
on his live stream he's 10 people ahead
of us it's a little bit lagged nice and
i was like oh [ __ ] i turned my back
because i didn't want people because we
were talking the whole way in line like
interviewing him and going back and
forth
but yeah i was definitely a little
scared that they would recognize that we
were together
um you know what was interesting i saw
you guys with dennis in back in ace fest
just not in the meet and greet fema
emergency camp
and um they didn't kick him out of the
festival just out of the mean it was
right out those doors how about that huh
they didn't kick them out they didn't
kick them out they just said move along
idiot
there you have it guys so acevex turned
was not as it kind of went off
uh without a hitch oh damn dude
i had a smile on my face all day
yesterday editing it too there you go
i was just reading austin is actually
from palmdale
so maybe he does
is from palmdale yeah so maybe he has
some kind of i forgot who told me that
or whatever maybe it was even death
mentioned that he had heard that or also
yet but i i heard from somebody that the
mcbrooms had some connection to that
venue okay also ace hat their company is
registered out there and that's where
their offices are palmdale yeah
jesus it was just from there originally
i go okay well shout the [ __ ] out dude
they made it happen
represent there you go i mean we went
there going to hate we went there to
hate but we just couldn't do it thank
you member berries for uh
50 gifted stuff i think that one might
actually be somebody different yeah that
might be someone new member berries
it's my birthday and a new episode is
the perfect day
so
that's that
um
shout out so open invitation to the us
to the mcbrooms and that's that and
that's that
um we've got a lot of other stuff what
else we got here um
i'll be honest nothing is quite as
interesting as that we do have the dolly
image generator i've been wanting to do
that
oh
are you up for that
that maybe we should save that for
wednesday because it's going to take a
bit yeah that's fatigued
really and cam is uh cam pulled uh
some a long weekend to get that
beautiful edit to us all oh what i
didn't know it had like involved work
for him to do the dolly too yeah
well so yeah you just type [ __ ] in yeah
but the whole concept of the sketch is
oh right man versus machine yeah yeah
right i want to be in my eight he wants
to be on his a-game got it got it got it
yeah you guys are for oh people keep
saying the james webb photos are out we
should show those
can you pull those up so james webb you
guys know it's the most powerful
telescope ever created by like a factor
of like 100
times stronger than uh
the hubble i've been waiting waiting
patiently for these james webb
photos let's [ __ ] get those up i
thought they didn't come out until the
14th
are they out early well i don't think
these are the full ones right
um i don't know people are just saying
james webb so i don't know
i i thought they were releasing four
photos
um i thought it was actually tomorrow 18
minutes ago nasa to unveil first images
yeah
i think only one today okay let's see it
they released one bring it up i want it
[Music]
give me the link
link i got it it's in there hold on
[Music]
spooky alien music
president biden what the why president
biden sharing it
how did he get involved in all this well
it's nasa i mean
he's the president
he's stealing clout from nasa bro
they've been working on this for decades
he wanted to win he's stealing clout
from his son being a [ __ ] baller all
over the internet oh yeah a hunter [ __ ]
dude dude hunter biden is having the
time of his life dude i'm jealous of how
much fun that [ __ ] is out there
having
dude that video
the fan cam
[Laughter]
dude he's hanging out with all these
hotties smoking crack
living it up man they're trying they're
trying to cancel him and they just
they're just making him more and more
powerful ej tj ain't got [ __ ] on her
body you know what
he's hunter biden's gonna be like doing
dj's he's gonna be a dj by the end of
the year flick at phone parties and [ __ ]
oh yeah like a million dollars again
probably done that dude he [ __ ] dude
hard well yeah he on camera right i mean
yes
and he's got a he's got a does he have a
hog i never saw well he's got a phd dude
he's got a doctorate he's got that
perfect hunter dong php my guy wait so
he really has a hog
the dude is packing heat yeah he's got a
phd dude the bidens huh yeah
a phd
pretty i've been seeing them saying that
on the housewives phd means
pretty huge dick is that what it means
well you're saying perfect honored
a perfect hunter dog more
curated
that means joe biden's packing probably
isn't that interesting
it could and a hair of legs and a big
old [ __ ] head i got it i got it i got
i got a big old [ __ ]
i learned about kids jumping on my lap i
got kids jumping on my big old car i got
your word straight jack
giant juicer
that's a juicer
anyway here it is back to nasa's ship
sneak peek at the deepest and sharpest
infrared image of the early universe
ever taken
all in a day's work for the webb
telescope
literally capturing it took less than a
day this is webb's first image released
as we begin to unfold the universe
i feel like i need more obviously it's a
beautiful photo but i feel like i need
more context
well to really appreciate i mean you're
looking back in time
billions and billions of years right
here which is pretty cool and of itself
that's kind of the whole
thing they're hoping to get out of this
uh telescope from what i understand
that you know the further you look the
further back in time you're seeing
essentially and so
we are
looking at a picture of the universe in
its early days which is pretty wild oh
that's sick i thought it was an iphone
wallpaper yeah i mean it looks yeah
exactly i mean i've seen screensavers
that are doper now let's let's re get
more details
on monday july 11th president joe biden
clout goblin released one of james
webb's telescope's first image in a
preview event
um
they will release a full set of webb's
first full color images
the first image from nasa's james webb
telescope is the deepest and sharpest
infrared image of the distant universe
to date known as webb's first deep field
this
image that was so fast bro
he was sitting on it
uh this image of galaxy cluster smacks
oh seven two three is overflowing with
detail
thousands of galaxies
that's what they said so this is smack
cam oh
it's
s-m-a-c-s i was just kind of
improvising it's not smacks it's max
thousands of galaxies including the
faintest objects ever observed in
infrared have appeared in webb's view
for the first time the slice of the vast
universe covers a patch of sky
approximately the size of a grain of
sand held at arm's length by someone on
the ground that's tiny
that's pretty incredible damn
one tiny grain of sand has got thousands
of galaxies in it that's [ __ ] nuts
someone in chat said you are seeing some
of the first stars and galaxies to form
after the big bang
that is pretty sweet
released one by one the first images
from the world's first and largest and
most powerful space telescope will
demonstrate webb at its full power ready
to begin its mission to unfold the
infrared universe
the first images will be added to this
page as the release so there you have it
a grain of sand
at arm's length bag of turret you know
flaming turd that's crazy bro that's
that's not so there you have it what's
this big boy here
who's this dirty dude
crushing it with that but mad vibes
there i think cam sent a closer up photo
and discord
okay here this is this you guys were
wondering what's the big star it's
hunter biden covering his tits
oh yeah
that does look like
imagine you're the this probably all
went down when when his dad was vp right
uh
no i think this happened even older
newer newer oh this happened since he
was president i don't think since trump
was no no no while trump was president
yeah but it was like within the last few
years definitely after obama was
president because the quality of the
phone he's recording on i mean he could
get his [ __ ] together
how old is he
i mean he could get his life together
later
yeah i mean he's a serious drug addict
yeah that's that sucks biden isn't a
sweet dad though every time there's they
try to like expose biden it's always
like really sweet unconditional love for
his son
he's 50 too [ __ ] bro
bag of meth and some camel we're gonna
get you clean buddy
52
i just you know i love this guy but i
don't think it makes joe biden look this
the whole thing is so pathetic i mean
come on if anything it makes them look
cooler in a way
got a son that [ __ ] dude you know
well i've seen that a lot out there that
take
i think it was matt watson who posted on
twitter the fact that he looks so much
like joe biden makes those videos so
much better dude really looks a lot like
joe that's what i'm saying joe biden's
got a fat [ __ ] uh geriatric hog dude
no wonder he tipped over on that bike
dude
yeah dude too much weight on one side
it's hard to ride a bike with the third
leg yeah dude
tripod
yeah there you go
cool man well let's keep showing the the
images as they come out it's pretty
exciting
stuff here bucko
but you know
it could go deeper though right deeper
like what's back here what's this you
know what i'm saying deeper
what's this
tell me about this
that's uh tatooine
deepa
that might be some type of nebula
um
what are you in an astronomer now i did
take a semester of it
oh and like guys tell me more about that
yeah what kind of nebula is it i'd
forgive me if i'm wrong here but isn't a
nebula
a star that nope you're wrong
it's gas it's just
then what is it when a
star explodes and creates galaxy
a supernova but that wouldn't create
galaxies that would create a nebulars
yeah stars so it's full circle
i don't think they know how galaxies are
made to be honest well i thought it's
stars exploding isn't that what it is
well galaxy galaxy's much bigger than
talking on totally different scales here
yeah galaxy has billions of trillions
maybe even stars in it
well look i don't think they know how
galaxies form exactly
i think they know that galaxies form
around supermassive black holes they've
recently confirmed that
but i don't think they know about the
formation of galaxies well you know
hashtag pangaea my guy
wow
hog nation
wow that was like a three-year-old call
back wait what did zach say i had a call
back too but then when it actually
overdated mine
i was gonna say you're thinking of the
tulip galaxy
he said hashtag pangaea which
we we
a conversation for like three years ago
on the show where
zach misunderstood what pangaea was and
then started vehemently arguing with all
of us oh that's not what happened
that's not what happened
you want to tell him cam i was just
going to say hashtag napoleon swam back
that's right i remember in the polls oh
he swam that was a good one yeah
napoleon swam
back from mexico that [ __ ]
slammed
across the channel or whatever that's
right dude but anyway there you go um
pretty exciting stuff uh we love it
joe biden clout goblin act like he took
this photo
[Laughter]
um but there you have it cool
beautiful keep it coming drop a like on
that
oh what are they saying there's more
intel here this isn't the furthest back
we've observed
okay
non-infrared missions like kobe
and wmap saw the universe closer to the
big bang about 380 000 years after
and there was only microwave background
radiation but no stars or galaxies webb
sees a few hundred thousand years after
the big bang
interesting
if you held a grain of sand up to the
sky at arm's length that tiny speck is
the size of the web's view in this image
imagine
galaxies galore within a grain
including light from galaxies that
traveled billions of years to us
i kind of want to click this go off go
don't show it
okay oh that's just a goof this is what
they posted
mcdonald's uh donald's yes sir okay now
this is epic
[Applause]
um
cool how long we've been going
uh two hours and 20 minutes
so i mean in terms of other stuff to do
we've got um
the gentle minions tick tock
we've got the elon musk
knocked up one of his top executives
at the same time as grimes class act yep
oh
who has more kids him or nick cannon he
does
he has more kids than mcbannon with the
twins he beats him they were tied but
the twins give him dude that's gnarly
because everyone's like nick cannon is
mentally ill the way he's having kids
with all these different baby mamas but
elon musk is doing it too
i don't know why elon musk is obsessed
with reproducing it's like dude you
don't you want those kids to actually
have a dad like having a bunch of kids
who are like [ __ ] up daddy issues is
not gonna help anyone
yeah
agree
especially billionaire ones guaranteed
those kids are gonna be one of those
kids at least is gonna be a serial
killer
guaranteed
well he's just trying to secure the
existence for his people in the future
of
the white right children yo elon tweet
he says doing my best to help under
population crisis a collapsing birth
rate is the biggest danger
civilization faces by far okay but you
know what
it's not true let's just well i
i think he's overstating it yeah
it seems like we're more plateauing
um then
collapsing birth rates but don't worry
about that elon
dude how much time a week you spend with
each one of your kids i mean seriously
dude do you even remember all their
names
he forgot x
i yeah he forgot the name during an
interview you're right he was like who
is who's that yeah and they're like
how's x ash whatever
he's like who who he's like oh i thought
you were telling me like a password or
something
idiot it's your child picture with the
pope
nick cannon replied to that by the way
sorry before you close it he goes mark
my words they are sadly true okay
whatever i saw a really funny meme it
was like
that
elon musk
pulled out of the twitter deal unlike
every time he has sex i don't know
something about him not being able to
pull out
yeah thank you nick can it says right
there with you my brother guys this is
not like funny you're just you're
creating fatherless kids i mean what the
[ __ ]
by the way elon posted this which is
like top
level copium cringe and people love it
a million likes i mean dude imagine
living in a world where people are just
simping for oligarchs this man is the
richest man in the world he's conning
everybody and people are just simping
for him like daddy yes please
i paid 13 billion in taxes this year
which was more than anyone ever lived
simp for me
yeah how much so what is your effective
tax rate like five percent shut up [ __ ]
five percent
they said i couldn't buy twitter
then they wouldn't disclose bot info now
they want to force me to buy twitter in
court now they have to disclose bot info
in court wow 5d chess no we all knew you
weren't going to buy it from the
beginning
there you have it
um
this is weird pretty cringy
thanks did you see elon musk's picture
with a pope he looks super funny
uh where no
i think it's on his twitter
[Music]
what's this i got here elon musk posted
a picture of
a elder ring boss why
i'm not sure there was no caption
just a picture of this elden ring boss
all right
very good very good
pretty cool
yep
very good
um yeah so also it just came out that
one of his top executives
for uh his neurolink company
just had twin babies by him isn't that
like unethical to be knocking up one of
your employees
yeah of course
especially while you are like have
another woman pregnant at the exact same
time yeah it just came out that while
grimes was giving birth to his kid xyz
ash 20 or whatever why z i don't know
uh this woman was giving birth secretly
to twins
what a legend they're just weeks in
between
dude he wants to be like genghis khan
like he's literally an olgar he goes
he's living like a [ __ ] king he goes
i'll [ __ ] everybody and anything have a
gillion kids and nobody's gonna tell me
what to do ever like and everyone's
going to worship me what should they do
by choice which is nuts and i'll give
you the biggest horse i have
for favors
allegedly oh yeah and the horse for
a handy that's some getting his con [ __ ]
here yeah i must say that i've had some
post-coital regrets about that phrase
so good i still think he could have
offered a better deal for a handy than a
horse just saying
two horse
it was two horses
that's a better deal two horses yeah one
pair of horses yeah
it is double
it depends on the horse
as we've talked about yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh that horse jizz but here she is
um i guess she's a pretty big deal she's
with justin trudeau
yeah she's very educated um
went to ivy league school
she's a
strong supporter of elon
she oh she's at yon simp yeah and she
changed the kid's name to mosque and um
well
i don't know i guess i shouldn't judge
her uh
her whatever she wants to do with her
family but
i don't know
you know what i'm saying
is this her she made a tweet about it
yeah no this is like
showing her okay she was like oh this is
20 20. yeah she's on twitter all the
time defending him his attackers and
stuff
he must love that lorenza uh gonzalez
fletcher said [ __ ] elon musk and then
she responded this makes me sad no one's
perfect but i never met anyone who goes
through more personal pain to fight for
an inspiring future for humanity and
done so tirelessly for decades
everyone's entitled to their opinion but
mine is that there's no one i respect
and admire more that's
kind of
nutty
that he knocked her up yeah and she has
like a cult like obsession with him i
feel like they're both going to try to
transcend their conscience together
like honestly i'm not even making a joke
i feel like
i could see them both
looking into that
you think they're trying to zap their
consciousness to the cloud i mean when
you have that complex already
thinking that you're an emperor
who wants to live forever well that's
what neural links all about yeah exactly
yeah it would make sense that they
they shared those ideals
yes because she's the cyberlink lady
yeah
she works on artificial intelligence
biological intelligence
well wasn't that biologically
intelligent to get knocked yeah maybe it
was she's probably set for life dude
and there is that those kids ain't gonna
have a dad though
and she says whatever exists between and
beyond yeah she's trying to live forever
you're right
freaks
but okay i mean listen if they if that's
what they want to do god bless
um
reminds me of epstein
remember epstein like all that was like
one of the other
weird things that he wanted to freeze
aside from the whole pedo thing he like
was freezing his sperm and like was
donating to all of these like colleges
that were researching like
gene
breeding and stuff like in eugenics and
all of that right like
that great irony he wanted to live
forever and yet he took his own life
hmm
fascinating isn't it
with the asterisks of course
a little asterisk there yeah
yeah so
um he says contrary to what many think
the richer someone is the fewer kids
they have i'm that rare exception
i i'm doing my part ha ha
there she is
[ __ ] oh man this guy's this guy [ __ ]
anything that walks bro
he'll give you a baby
you want a baby he's giving out babies
well at least you know he can afford it
nick cannon i'm not so sure i know he's
like rich but like with 13 kids that
[ __ ] racks up man
like what's nick cannon worth these days
he used to do america's got talent right
his show on
45 million oh he's fine
he can have another 20 babies
yeah yeah
it's not a billion but
it should be okay yes that's enough yeah
that's enough
well there you go man elon is such a
[ __ ] weirdo dude it's just crazy i
the weirdest thing about him that makes
me hate him the most is just his
whole meme thing that he thinks he's
like this meme guy and he steals memes
and but it's just it's [ __ ] whack and
weird it's like pathological it makes me
like
the dude repost nine gag memes all day
and i don't know it's just kind of
[ __ ] up don't you think
yeah we have one of them in the dark
oh really yeah it's highlighted right
here under the twitter deal it's right
under that section
[Music]
um musk pulls out of the twitter deal
let's take a look
so a b coming out with uh another great
moment here abe just told me to open
this
yeah i know you already looked at the
first one but keep scrolling oh okay
okay sorry i can't see the future i'm
trying here no no no
when you tell me to edit last night is
when i added it
[Music]
a b notorious for not you know
i'm not going to throw i'm not even
going to criticize you i'm saying not
paying attention but you do have had
several moments where you send me
things that we just talked about i
thought because
i'm the only one that has to listen to
other stuff no it's great you're doing
your job and we love that
oh god the chuck mate
did
it's so cringy dude
by the way he has one piece i think
that's an l bro i think you lost big
time yeah
i don't
pretty sure that's a loss
chuck mate oh yes so he found this on
nine gag dude
and he it was called chuck mate
so epic
i'm sorry but he's reposting nine games
so flow vibes it's literally like
yep you're all playing checkers while
i'm playing chess so so so why does it
is it cool when elon is
doing exactly what soflo did
and he got
like laughed off the internet for it
10 years ago
anyway
shout the [ __ ] out
to elon musk
father of nine kids
and still producing
yup exactly
who will die with more kids uh nick
cannon or elon we shall see
yeah and of course elon pulled out of
the twitter deal which many of us
knew and predicted would happen
um
rudy g oh so anyway moving on rudy
giuliani rudy giuliani is selling
slides this was a july 4th special
disgusting this man was the mayor of new
york
and a [ __ ] president
attorney
this dude straight up tweeting out great
products at a reasonable price use code
rudy for additional savings
[ __ ] rudy giuliani out here
with new sandals regular price 80 bucks
on sale for 50 great savings
mypillow.com promo code rudy ladies and
gentlemen we love that booty giuliani
you nasty filthy sloppy disgusting
filthy [ __ ] animal yes
i love that sound but i've been waiting
for that
that of course is uh what's his name
michael rapp reporter yeah yeah
uh
this is just awesome i mean this is
idiot right here it's a sexual dance
dude rudy's down bad he's [ __ ]
slinging sandals
what do you have to do with sandals rudy
i bet you his feet are so [ __ ] up you
know his his
are all black and yellow
[ __ ] animals
this guy ain't never putting on sandals
oh
boy so we love that oh he totally he
deleted it well after the sale oh yeah
after he made his bag i wonder how much
he sold
i think he needs every dollar they can
get right now here we go oh [ __ ] they're
even more discounted now
on mypillow.com they were 50. 49.99 now
they're 39.98
so
the savings go even deeper folks
um code rudy
use code rudy
all sizes are still available
in black gray black or black
disgusting
[Laughter]
so a whole bunch of options here yeah
testimonials
seem legit let's see testimonials five
star reviewed by rudy
[Laughter]
great product at reasonable price wait
that's literally what he said oh yeah
you re you reviewed your own
wait
[Music]
you wrote this review seven one that's
the day he posted yes no that's rudy
giuliani's review rudy you left a review
of your own damn sandal oh my god that's
such a good catch holy [ __ ]
well you know he was smart to do that
because that's 25 percent of the ratings
right there so yeah those are only four
yeah
wait can i leave a review
one star
is that [ __ ] up yeah no no no you
literally got sued for this no hold on
i'll do five stars
i'll say not rudy
giuliani
hey i don't know how spells last time
hold on
just you know what don't even look it up
just spell it out no this i need to
convince you g.i
you won't be disgusting
[ __ ] animal
best sandals
ever made
[ __ ] my tits an [ __ ]
just leave it with all the typos it's
funnier no stop little nas
why mike why can't i spell sandals you
guys
is it
[Music]
and then why is it not giving me an
autocorrect
i'm not laughing at you buddy i can't
spell you
something
it's right above well no it's jill and
august sandals
it says men's slide sandals at the top
s-a-n-d-a-l-f [ __ ] best sandals ever
made
not rudy giuliani
love these sandals
[Music]
i got mine for 49.99
and now
it's 39.99
[Music]
yup can i get my 10
10 bucks back
great sandals by the way
still love them
called rudy
let's see if this makes it to the
website
yeah dude dude tell me it's there
already now they gotta review it
damn
i feel like that might they might slip
by
i'll keep checking on it but let's read
the other ones been using my pillow for
10 years what the [ __ ] does it even
about the sandals
there's only four reviews on the whole
website mint slide sandals for father's
day i cannot wait for my men's slide
sandals for further away [ __ ]
you don't even have them
i cannot wait for them you said yeah
five stars
how do you know
wilbur said about to order my third pair
so let me get this straight this guy's
been using it for 10 years
and this guy needs three pairs yup yeah
i mean i believe one guy's from the
future
with the quality slippers i'm very
excited to get the sandals too so he
also he has never worn them yet he has
three pairs
i dare you to post my real review one of
the names for was i gal or igal
does that stand for interconnectional
grouping of accountants possibly
or i guess
yeah i'll just google it what does it
mean
no no if you go down there's like a
accountant's lawyer thing for him
intercontinental grouping of accountants
and lawyers
interesting
that might be an organization he's a
part of you think yeah so he wrote so
rudy coming out with those two reviews
from the old accounts
to sexual dance
anal sex
what a [ __ ] goon dude what the [ __ ]
dude had this my fellow guy he made like
100 million dollars from this [ __ ] he's
like rich as hell
that's awesome man
wait is he still doing it oh my god this
dude has steve bannon on his website
like one of the greatest provocateurs uh
propagandist
white supremacist piece of [ __ ] in the
world
you proudly sponsoring steve bannon's
war room
pandemic special
[Music]
jesus of 300 million mike lindell's
network 300 million from this [ __ ]
site what the [ __ ] dude
how do you make that much money selling
pillows anyway
how many pillows you sell it's only 20
bucks too how much you call how much
how much you making these pillows for
it's an awful product though
estimations are kind of all over the
place i'm pretty sure i tried one a long
time ago because like you're always in
the market for a good pillow right it
was horrible yeah it sucked
it's so funny that suck
oh my god dude dude he used to be like
all over like qvc and like hsn like just
slinging that [ __ ]
oh you can buy this poster by the way
this uh
vanessa's satin print line of judah
wait that's fire
isn't that like the passion of the
christ like movie poster jesus
with the lion no not the lion but i mean
like oh behind jim caviezel cavizzle the
actor
that we're talking about you can get
this on sale with promo code 28 bucks
it's a uh the one of the elders said to
me do not weep
see the lion of the tribe of judah the
root of david
mom and dad has triumphed he is able to
open the scroll and its seven seals
revelation five
not to do our boy austin dirty like this
what happened but i have received this
give it to me from a fan only that you
get great parking free parking need to
meet the ace family
dude i knew he said free partners and he
they wrote it somewhere too only that
you get great parking free parking
another broken promise
yeah it was 10 bucks to park it's no no
no it's free after you pay
yeah
there are free parking spaces maybe
that's what he meant oh they're
available like they're physically
available right you have to pay for them
but then there will be free
spots available for you too that's a
very generous uh interpretation you guys
love sucking up that donut okay maybe if
we showed him our vip when we first got
in there
it's possible i mean i didn't hell no
what the [ __ ] mike liddell's selling
stop bleeding in seconds
[Laughter]
what bleed stop oh that's a good deal
what the [ __ ] is this for minor cuts to
large bleeding wounds just band-aids
lard no it's some kind of powder
bleed stop for large gaping wounds for
chemo is it hemophilia where let's see
you don't blood clot or whatever yeah it
says um
used by hospitals and first responders
keep your children and families safe
be prepared
bleed stop uh test on the next episode
we all cut our palms and pour some of
this [ __ ] on there here he does a video
about it
is he gonna cut his palm let's see this
[ __ ] bruh i am mike lindell
[Laughter]
there's no better product to stop
massive
major pleading with this
um
why is there no audio i need to hear a
broil here
i was faced with every adversity you
could think of by the grace of god i was
able to get through all that and learn
from it i have a passion to help other
u.s entrepreneurs and that's why i
created mystore.com
we have thousands of products available
and today i want to show you one of them
called bleed stop we've all been there
just when you least expect it or when
you might be running behind you
accidentally cut yourself wouldn't it be
great to have a quick and easy way to
stop bleeding hello i'm mike lindell bro
how many times are you like
fatally bleeding at home that a band-aid
isn't good enough for
i wanted to be
i'll never forget one time
well i mean i'm sure like this is a
product you could get in any pharmacy
like why is he selling it's just such a
a niche product
i'll never forget one time
i was high on crack
i was totally delirious and i cut my
whole finger off i i
i smashed through a glass door of a
restaurant trying i couldn't see the
restaurant and i was all [ __ ] up on
crack i smashed through that [ __ ] my
face was gushing blood i thought i would
die for sure and through the kitchen
came an angel named jesus he had with
him a bleed stop he poured it on my face
the bleeding stopped instantly and i
haven't forgot that angel since
plead stop could save your family
i was doing crack with hunter biden one
time
i was doing that the pipe broke
the pipe broke and shattered my wrist
an angel came and poured this on me his
name was actually angel
he was a good man
suck the mean [ __ ]
those days are long behind me now
use code angel
get part of bleed stop because it works
it helps people and it's made in the usa
i get approached by people all the time
gushing
it's truly one of the best it says
major cuts minor cuts to major wounds
bro that's like ebola
yeah what the [ __ ]
my son was attacked by a bear his blood
was everywhere the bear was halfway done
to consuming his flesh i put some bleed
stuff on him and it closed all of his
wounds immediately my son still died but
the blood that we saved that day meant
everything people come up to me on the
street all the time with blood just
gushing like a [ __ ] fire hose like
kill bilge
i keep blood with me in a flask and
splash it on the wounds i see
people think i'm a saint i'm just a man
with bleed stop
oh
i've ever seen
if you've ever been frustrated by a
minor cut that won't stop bleeding or
had an accident or an emergency
situation where you want to quickly stop
bleeding you need bleed stop it's a safe
non-stinging organic powder that's
clinically proven to quickly and eat
promo code
stop bleeding and start healing everyday
cuts scrapes and even major wounds
bandages can be clumsy sure they'll
cover your wound but they don't do much
to stop the bleeding bleed
works simply put bleed stop onto any cut
or wound apply pressure and watch the
bleeding stop bleed stop is fda cleared
and effective for people on blood
thinners
i've heard fda approved i don't i don't
know what fda cleared what does fda
cleared mean
anybody
anybody out there in the audience sounds
like fda cleared and with you wherever
you go help protect yourself your family
and loved ones bleed stop is a necessity
easy to apply it doesn't burn it doesn't
sting it's truly one of the best
products i've ever seen so go to
mystore.com and use the best product
i've ever seen right behind my collagen
pills
right here my collagen raspberry
lemonade pills
what does collagen do i don't even know
donald the caveman books
he has like the pet please over for pets
too i don't know if you saw that bleed
clot for pets bro what the [ __ ]
so niche it's like
bleed clot for hamsters collagen helps
first skin electricity
what does he have a video for this one i
need a separate box for my beds more
about this ideal for dogs cats birds and
other pets
when used in grooming settings bleed
clot pets collague technology makes
uh stiff tick powder obsolete okay
this store is kind of slaps have you
seen donald the caveman though
it's such a strange assortment of
products here
donald the caveman drains the swamp
mike's the most irl tim and eric
character out there i agree i mean his
life is so true is like a cinco
commercial
yo so why is donald a caveman
donald it's just not that flattering
right after donald the caveman draved
the swamp and built the wall everyone
was happy everyone that is except
freedom haters who called themselves the
resistance is this a pillow website
led by an evil sorceress named madame
miss speaker
the resistance tried to contract ever
contradict everything donald said to
make himself seem like a bad leader so
are you just trying to brainwash kids
like what the [ __ ] i mean yeah
it seems like
they pretty quickly dropped the pretense
of this being like a
like a children's book like they're just
talking about like just politics you
know halfway through the paragraph
dude this is [ __ ] nuts
that aoc on the right yeah that must be
bernie bernie and uh pelosi oh and the
tweet the twitter birds are snapping on
them
based on a true story it says
these people are mentally ill man
they have a tooth repair
kits yes
where's that i need the two i've sent a
bunch of stuff in discord
wait
if you go deep into like
like in the back end you can find some
weird [ __ ] what's on clearance i wonder
uh it's all just pillows and [ __ ]
why did you swim [ __ ] on his website
wait is this real
hold on
send me links okay
what are the odds from crack addict to
ceo what's that that's the cover
no it's just like sure
i guess that's just like this is me on
crack
i love the mustache always stayed the
same even in crack addiction that [ __ ]
stayed heavily manicured
what are the odds
from crack addict to ceo back to crack
addict
my journey
oh yeah let me see this this is [ __ ]
amazing temporary tooth replacement kit
temporary dent have you can you not
afford to go to the dentist look matt
walsh used it
if you need to if you need all your
money for crack you're not going to be
able to afford to go to the dentist bro
what is this
if you need teeth for a second
what am i looking like teeth for a
moment looks like caviar
fool proof do-it-yourself pro i think we
need one of these
fool proof do it yourself no special
equipment and needed online
instructional videos how the hell
does the
tooth placement [ __ ] dude this [ __ ]
website rules dude
there's no reviews to the teeth stuff so
i feel like we should be the first i
didn't get that try rephrasing your
question or start over hey you can buy a
mike lindell life-size cutout cardboard
for 40 bucks
seriously
should we buy one of these oh we kind of
do need get your very own mike lindell
life-size cutout all proceeds go to the
lindell recovery network what does that
mean
oh there's a bunch of reviews check this
out fun surprise
my friend surprised me on my birthday by
putting this outside my kitchen window
so when i woke up i saw him in the
window it startled me and it made me
laugh we love you mike
that is
that sounds terrifying that's [ __ ]
insane i'm trying to get assistance from
their chat bot it's not it's not going
well
who wants a mike lindell cut out
he has his own tab here he under mike's
products it says mike's books mike cut
out
and frank's speech products
look i started this with like kind of
[ __ ] around and i said uh how the
hell does the tooth replacement [ __ ]
work i didn't get that try refreezing
your question started over let me talk
to mike i didn't get that
i have a question about amazing
temporary tooth i didn't get that i need
assistance i didn't get that [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what's the point of your robot
ass
all right we've spent enough time on
mypillow.com all right
so
shout out mike lindell somehow i don't
even know how we got here
we were talking about rudy that's oh
yeah called rudy
stop bleed please don't buy a cutout
directly from him so yeah yeah i mean
it's true i don't really want to give
him any money
we'll get a bootleg
we'll get an aftermarket mic
yeah uh wendy williams i'm so sad to say
not only was her show canceled they
brutally erased all of her social media
accounts
they're trying to make her an instagram
page with 2 million followers gone
gone bro
they're wiping her memory clean
you know this was a write-up from last
week
um are we sure
on instagram
i mean i don't want it to be true but
it wasn't wendy's account it was the
show's account right but still why
they've got to do her dirty like that
she has a legacy yeah i think that they
the tv's out there just don't want to
monetize her stuff like they don't want
to give her money
so you think it was a bad breakup
oh yeah really they didn't even let her
host the finale of her own show i wonder
why they were such she's been such
punks about it also on her instagram
page there's a video of her and she's
talking about how like
people don't want her to have her money
and and they're trying to keep her money
away from her
really yeah there's definitely you think
there's conservatorship going on
there's something
in the same genre i think at least
the final episode aired june 17th
without her
um
a source for ok magazine claims the plan
is to rename wendy's official account to
sherry shepherd
thus sherry oh that makes sense thus
sherry's show
will debut with millions of
social media fans who's sherry shepard
how's she gonna replace wendy williams
she was on the um she was on the view
for a long time okay
um she's just been in the entertainment
this is sherry oh i recognize her
but does she i wonder if she's gonna
have that wendy william like sass bro
like death to all of them type [ __ ] you
know what i mean
she seems too nice i don't know anything
about her
but she gonna be having that blasting
ass on
camera vibe
death to all of them vibe
die clap if they should suffer i don't
doubt it that was the magic that made
william wendy great should she suffer
clap if they should be um incarcerate
clap if they should be burnt alive
well that's sad
you know
well she's starting a podcast
oh i hope she tells all
that's i wonder if we could get her
let's get her have we reached out
wait have we reached out yeah i've tried
i'll keep trying yo everybody we need
wendy we need that podcast collab yo we
need wendy williams on our show right
[ __ ] now bro starting a podcast you
know she's going to be doing promo and
just show her the
what we did with howie mandel we put his
ass on the map dude
can do the same thing for her well
i made howie
you're wondering
and also like the immediate aftermath of
that wasn't
i'm just really the best i'm just
kidding
but he does owe me
uh his whole career
um
oh how he responded
he said thanks for making me a teddy
fresh spokesman
[Laughter]
i don't get it because the ad you posted
there's a oh he saw that oh [ __ ] okay
oh
i love howie he's the man
are you saying love you
it's so funny
yeah dude that is going to live forever
it's [ __ ] amazing i mean who could
ever get away with posting a prolapse
only how we could get away with that bro
if i posted that chat be done for it
yeah it was just so unexpected
loved that
anyway i guess that's about it eh
uh yeah we've been going three hours now
oh i do love this story tobuscus hay
game with kyle rittenhouse
is that a [ __ ] nightmare or what
tobuscus the fallen youtuber
is hanging out for some god known reason
with kyle [ __ ] rittenhouse with nerf
guns like trying to make light of the
fact that you know he killed two people
douche like what's the vibe here bro
what are we what are we doing exactly
building a nerf team with some random
people i ran into on the sidewalk who's
in good to see this kid is off the hard
stuff and onto nerf
on an unrelated note one of these guys
has a video game coming out
rittenhousegames.com what are the odds
so so he's there
to promote
kyle rittenhouse the famous video game
producer
what he's known the man famous for
literally killing two people
uh super stoked on his video game
thanks tobiscus
bro what is wrong with you doug is this
a paid thing
even if it is it's still weird
i can't still get over the fact that
like conservatives made this guy into a
hero
this just blows my mind still
yeah
dude this is so [ __ ] tasteless bro
even if what you did was self-defense
right like how [ __ ] tasteless is this
just if you did it for self-defense why
would you want to be associated with all
this [ __ ] about like
yeah [ __ ] guns and i killed two
people who had it coming it was like
what do you want to distance yourself
from all this [ __ ]
what are the comments i hope they're
horrible the comments on the youtube
video are pretty
good oh there's a youtube video yeah a
link
it's in the
timestamp
all this
he talks about him like he's a hero yeah
why y'all don't like kyle um
well
he did kill two people
and now he's being made a hero a poster
boy of killing protesters for no reason
well not for no reason but he went there
looking for trouble
how the gods have fallen no kidding oh
bro this is nuts dude
what's next uh
who's that dude the black dude who
killed the mexican kid
george uh oh
uh jamie yeah
he's you have a bit backwards zimmerman
is mexican yeah oh i thought oh yeah
you're right i'm sorry
zimmerman who's what's next a collab
with zimmerman video game
didn't he
end up going to jail for something else
i wouldn't be surprised at all
um
yo i didn't know you made a video let's
watch that where is it
it's right here
right where in the doc right under
oh my bad
it was a discord
hello dude
what the [ __ ] tobiscus what the [ __ ] bro
is this spontaneously my thoughts on
kyle the media our culture and your mom
all right once again audience
uh hope i didn't lose you yesterday
because i posted a picture of uh me
being with this uh
oh wait like
a person
he says the p word is that okay
p word
p u s s what the p e d o or
p e d l
what ass p word
toby does he says pedo please put says i
think you could say pedo
what context though we did twice just
now
all the time on the show yeah we say it
all the time
and i really wanted to meet your matters
i'm so excited i wanted to meet him ever
since i saw the the whole video where he
uh unfortunately took the lives of
a couple convicted pedophiles
oh he's celebrating wait can i get some
volume
wait tobiscus is out here celebrating
our boy wanted to meet this kid i was so
excited i wanted to meet him ever since
i saw the
whole video where he uh unfortunately
took the lives of a couple convicted
pedophiles
yeah did he know that they were that uh
when he killed them right it's so
[ __ ] dumb dude like
oh he was a bad guy so it doesn't matter
that he killed him well what the [ __ ] he
didn't even know a [ __ ] about that when
he shot them
dumb ass freak
tobiscus you [ __ ] animal
sweaty looking
he's on some [ __ ] for sure
um
and he didn't go looking for that yes he
did
didn't he he literally did yeah and he
literally did he literally did
they attacked him first he was like a
pedophile hunter people should stop
praising him for hiding pedophiles he
didn't even know he didn't know their
pen pals he probably thought they were
black
well he is down the meme hole bad what
tobiscus is down
dude didn't you just make videos for
kids what the [ __ ] this is literally
yeah he says in this video like i assume
i i like raised this kid but i guess he
didn't know who i was but he like
assumed that this kid was a big fan of
his and
this is on his main channel or well his
second channel i guess what the [ __ ] and
he opens his video with this [ __ ] too
like oh my god
no he uh he knew they were white
and uh you know they were
you know they were maybe burning down
the city and there was no police and
this kid in this age where we were
raised on video games
this is actually the real one that was
the one we saw was photoshopped
but yeah that's uh kyle rittenhouse uh
right
he's crying so we love that for him
goes out there he's like you know what
i'm going to go on a mission and i'm
going to help people
better than the better than the
alternative i'm going to go on a mission
and i'm on a loot walmart and then i'm
going to burn it down and then i'm going
to burn down the buildings next to it
and then i'm going to beat up an old
lady and then i'm on it and dinner but
he's still doing the tobiscus voice for
kids about like killing protesters
because this is good content he used to
do this voice for his dog and it was
like the kids loved it he's still doing
the tobiscus voice now i'm on a loot
walmart and then i'm going to burn it
down and then i'm going to burn down the
buildings next to it and then i'm going
to beat up an old lady and then i'm on
it and then i'm on it and then dinner
how funny is it that we love
we by we i mean
america or whatever the world
yeah it's like it's like we love heroes
in movies
but when it comes to like police
officers they're like
they're not heroes that's their job what
the [ __ ] dude this is crazy
dude tobiscus is like a [ __ ] police
simp bootlicker
this is awesome man this is nuts wait
the comments are good yeah
i said
holy [ __ ]
i swear it seriously feels like our
original timeline merged with a
different one
i convinced him being on the annoying
orange show somehow pipelined him into
this
[Laughter]
back in my day toby sang songs about
nuggets and biscuits how the times have
changed
i genuinely feel like i have
schizophrenia watching this no [ __ ]
i think the riddler is behind all of
this
could have sworn i took my pills this
morning i feel like i'm in a fever dream
i'm dreaming this isn't happening
tobiscus the same man who let me know i
could not afford his diamond sword has
not really has not released a video
about kyle rittenhouse i've died and
this is what comes next
the child in me couldn't fathom what
kind of timeline we're currently living
in
remember that this dude was in the
annoying orange tv show for his cartoon
network
oh my god
toby went from entertaining me for years
as a kid to comparing kyle rittenhouse
to batman
yeah we have that time stamp
dude this is nuts
oh this is the like dislike ratio that's
good
oh [ __ ]
this is crazy that he put this out there
he's not just a conservative he's like a
boot-licking cop simp
[ __ ]
death to protesters
i mean he's doing a heroic thing he's
protecting him you turn up a little bit
nobody likes police officers right
uh
except robocop it's very very cool uh
judge dredd she's pretty sweet anyways
but the real live ones nobody likes
those okay they're you know they're
they're great but you know
there's some bad ones whatever but
that's just uh that's how it is people
some people suck
and then you fire those people bro the
police is like corrupt all the way
through there's no accountability you
can [ __ ] kill someone in cold blood
take a two-week vacation and come back
on the force or just get transferred to
another
department like a pedophile priest
come on bro there's systematic issues
with the police you can't just dismiss
it like there's a few bad apples and uh
get the better ones and then you find
the the make the people better you want
to fund them you don't want to defund
them so
but it's it's just funny that we don't
for some reason somehow people stop
looking at it as like the guy that you
call to help you
to save you from crazy criminals with
blue hair or whatever
nah blue hairs
nah
do what are the blue haired people do
they just did you [ __ ] even
yeah
what is this you didn't even like
if you're gonna put something like this
out you should at least edit or think
about it like this is a big thing to
come out as
blue hair was that a social justice
warrior thing
a scream they just uh
they just right
i don't know if they're actually violent
i'm totally i have no idea i love blue
hair by the way it's cool
and i love hair dye and all that's
awesome
but uh people blue hair are crazy but uh
no
um
what was i talking about we love dude
are you
serious right now
just edit it or something bro
this is shocking
batman you know we love this hero he
goes out the city's burning down
gotham's burning and he puts himself
right in the line of danger right we
teach
our kids to do that by making those
movies
and you blame kyle a child
for going out when he was asked by his
friends family because they had a
business
someone burned and shot up their other
location or something they did day
before a couple days this is the last
thing they had they had nothing left it
was like i don't think that's true
i think he went there from a different
town
he heard that there was some store that
was like being righted i don't even
think he was near the store yeah he was
literally provoking these people he was
walking around with a [ __ ]
ar
just intimidating them
and also and begging for some [ __ ] to
happen side note but batman doesn't kill
people
he doesn't use weapons either he refuses
to use guns right yeah and he i don't
think he ever kills people no he doesn't
that's like his whole quote yeah he he's
above that [ __ ]
also it's not a real also he's not real
right
right that was very funny sorry also
it's like you realize it's a comic it's
actually just a comic book wait isn't it
like okay never mind
yeah it's a he's like you guys love
superman but hate written kyle kyle
rittenhouse explain that [ __ ] liberals
could you maybe i don't know defend it
or something like you know you're a
you're like a trained was he a medic boy
scout
freaking this like a baby this is like
this guy was training for this moment
he's like i'm going to help people
that's you know
believe that or not but you know
they asked him to defend it he comes up
there puts out a fire a literal dumpster
fire puts out a fire in a dumpster that
a bunch of uh riddler you know from
batman i wish someone would put out this
dumpster fire sitting in the car making
this video right now
thanks after my what can i get a drum
roll or something
uh work with me work with me people
bingo
bingo hello
what is that called the drum thing a
something shot rim shot yeah rick shot
rick shot people
rim rim job oh rim shot rim jump shot
i'm a walking rim shot work with me
and like
gas lit
psychopaths burn uh set fire to this
dumpster to push it into a gas station
to blow it up
you weren't there i wasn't there it's
hard to understand you have to imagine
that's happening down your street it's
not history
yeah he didn't even live there
especially we literally went there with
the ar looking for trouble bro he didn't
even live there [ __ ]
for the police somebody said he's
literally joking on his nasal drip
dude he is son some crazy
he looks so sweaty and gnarly right now
something what drug makes you angry
speed
speed uppers yeah i mean like speed
makes you super sweaty super
dude that'd be crazy if he was doing
speed
it's awesome
love that racist and you're like most of
the people that they protect are
minorities and in a lot of the areas a
lot of specifically like chicago a lot
of these cities oh my god mostly
minority police officers and you'd still
you so ask the people in chicago how
they feel about the police
they're there to protect them
these blue-haired crazy people screaming
at black police officers calling them
racist why don't you go to chicago and
ask people there how they feel about
them and see what they say
yeah i'm sure the chicago police
department is one as a
stellar uh
reputation chicago police department dan
have they had any um
controversy
oh no they have a sterling reputation
you're talking about the chicago police
department that ran uh secret black
sites where they would kidnap people and
without charge oh they would do that
yeah somebody should tell to viscous
that because he thinks there's here
they're [ __ ] saints and it's only
blue hair people that hate them
so that's this is the age we live in
where uh people really hate uh hated uh
kind he said that chicago police
department is mostly minority police
what percentage of chicago pd is white
i'm curious or
do we get that stat let's just fact
check our boy tobiscus here
for uh being attacked because he went
out there with a
gigantic weapon you know that's everyone
who's done that what's that
oh never mind i'm sorry let me let me
it's 50 white 25
hispanic 21
african american three percent asian
american slash pacific islander so it's
not majority i mean
no the majority would be white
interesting
um but
i wouldn't run into a burning building
either i mean that has a job i mean you
know
i think he ran into a building and
neither have you
we don't know how we would act but we
have been raised that uh we've been
taught that heroes are we don't know how
we would act but the media is no such
thing blm protest what i i feel like i
wouldn't have shot people at a protest i
mean if i i got gas
into several protests i i managed to not
shoot anyone so
right well i would certainly want to
want to provoke like a huge mob
with the ar especially when the police
bet like say don't go there right
on this countdown of the seven most
corrupt police cities in history
chicago's number three oh come on that
can't be true people everyone loves
chicago police except the blue-haired
freaks like wait what's number one
number one
what is this countdown is this like yeah
countdown top both corrupt ten
your account mojo
what you got new york city's number one
shout out number two miami greatest city
in the world baby number four los
angeles let's go
lapd we are very young we gotta bump
those numbers up we can't be beaten by
chicago and new york look we acknowledge
that there's some brave and good police
officers but to just write it off like
the police don't need to be reformed
from the is is ludicrous i mean come on
there's literally no accountability
someone said tobiscus
is 100
subscribed to paul joseph watson yeah
yeah
it's not the same as heroes they're just
doing their job they don't care about
you
maybe maybe they like the power trip
but you want police officers to be
powerful and you want them to be
competent and confident and respected
and no accountability
and unless they don't deserve it
respect is something you have to earn
and if you lose it
goodbye dude
you know it's hard it takes a long time
and this is where it begins is you
instill values of a person that you
respect in other people and kids you
know and kids are the most important
people uh because they are the future
and if we don't want the future to suck
you how to make the kids not suck
uh and that's why i personally i think i
feel and that's why i think hoards of
children
should get all get their armed ar-15s i
want to send a hordes of children army
to intercept all of these rioters and
protesters
i'm calling all kids between the age of
14 and
17 to pick up arms
and meet me this saturday outside
planned parenthood
[Music]
too much
it's a hypothetical yeah yeah yeah no
yeah you're good still maybe extra
responsibility for this because
go ahead dan
i have to admit i i don't know jack [ __ ]
about taboo yeah he had a huge scandal
but there's a lot say it uh yeah so but
i saw people saying that he had already
been canceled oh yeah oh he got [ __ ]
he was dude he got bombed on dude he got
absolutely body he was like one of the
biggest names on youtube at one point he
was up there
yeah but his ex april fletcher says uh
made several allegations against the
youtuber and careful with what you he
was addicted to drugs
yeah i got you he cheated on several of
his former partners including fletcher
and that he drugged and r-worded her in
february 2013. so
cool
awesome and then um i remember this
jaclyn glenn another of his
ex-girlfriends
posted a response video she claimed that
turner had affairs
and that she thought the r word
allegations were possible
she
personally believed that they were
untrue what
why would you put that out there
uh okay whatever
you know i saw kyle obviously as an
egomaniac i assumed he watched all my
videos growing up i was like i raised
this kid
but then i talked to him and he's like i
never heard of you i was like oh
well i don't
i don't like you no uh
and so if i didn't write them who did i
raise
oh no
the i hate to break it to you buddy but
i don't think many people remember your
ass
sorry
hurry
sorry
pilot gaslit riddler army
um i didn't really raise anybody i just
made some silly videos but that's the
thing i was looking up at one point in
my uh
career we would call it that uh
thousands and thousands of hours
thousands of years of humanity
consciousness was i was
soaking it up what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with kyle rittenhouse [ __ ]
you are on a drug fueled rant right now
you literally can't even follow one
conscious thread
anyway kyle rittenhouse is a hero and i
raised kids they used to watch me
thousands of hours jack with a hairy
legs and a big old [ __ ]
i did crack with prostitutes got in the
elevator man took a picture of my [ __ ]
hairy legs
i'm riding that bikes they're going to
fell to the side my [ __ ] too heavy jack
you ever ride with the third leg
i was gonna put him
for someone that hates joe biden
probably he sure acts a lot like him and
his son
i was absorbing it
waking human life
thousands of years
well maybe it's hundreds
let's just say thousands were
spent watching me play video games
or whatever you know and in those video
games i did my best i was trying to i
was trying to project a positive a kyle
renton house is a hero just like me jack
i used to play video games for kids they
watched me for hours man
with the hair legs and the ice cream
and the babysitters
come on man
what a stupid song [ __ ]
come on fat
yeah it's kind of he was one of the
biggest youtubers in the world for a
while he was like dominating he was like
on top of pewdiepie he was the [ __ ] dude
damn yeah he was up there you don't know
you didn't know that i pewdiepie
i gotta tell you
i
only
really
started
paying attention and knowing youtubers
when i started working for you
oh i was never like on youtube that much
so a lot of these like older school
youtube people
like when we first started talking about
the whole dobrick uh saga yeah i had no
idea who the vlog's oh that's
interesting never heard of them
yes so um but he was a huge deal
actually
i mean he's been canceled for a long
[ __ ] time now but he was
a huge deal man it was in 2016 when he
got canceled oh [ __ ] it was that long
ago i know it seems like it was more
recent but right so if he got cancelled
in 2016 though right yeah 2016 is when
the first allegation came out and then
just the dominoes sort of started to
fall after that
whoa
and he was like big deal he was doing
commercials for like hot pockets and
[ __ ] you should pull up some of the
content it's crazy pull up one of those
hot pocket ads i just want to show dan
what the [ __ ] he missed
the quality content dude he was nuts man
oh yeah he used to make music and the
angry orange he was part of that most
people are familiar with that
yeah that unfortunately i'm familiar
with that
and i was trying to not super swear
because i wanted kids to be allowed to
watch it i didn't want to swear man but
this kid with the gun he killed people
that's a hero man
long he don't say no curse words and
shoot bang bang kill him dad man
pedophiles and [ __ ] kill him mike
i'll tell you no cursing though joe
three oh three
three oh
oh man i love it it's so awesome yeah
here it is dan this one's for you hey if
you guys don't know who tobiscus is
he used to do this trapped in a
commercial series but he would actually
they are just actually ads he probably
got was banking and back then 2013
5 million views that was insane that was
insane
you guys were just starting out around
then right
honestly i don't even remember probably
yeah
check this [ __ ] out you're gonna love it
he's still in bed
[Music]
shut up open up the freezer to get some
snackages to hot pockets sandwich
packages what is this hot pockets
commercial why is the music so
disproportionately epic
there's a force field on the freezer
till he reads the label then he can grab
the box and go to the table yeah you get
the idea it's great stuff um
members go up
i have gotten a hold of them you did who
are they
let's find out i asked for proof and
i want to know
i want to know are they rich or they
have like a good job like how do they
afford it i think they're watching right
now so they should be hearing yeah i
just want to know who's this mystery
person
hey girlfriend dance yeah oh yeah this
is the voice i was telling you about
when he was like go kill the bro go kill
the protesters called rhett and health
he does this like cute dog voice or i'll
give you away griffin he's nervous i was
just casting information for hot pockets
limited edition and i think there's a
sufficient amount of how to not involved
so we're going to post it here roll the
flips
hey steve bargain here with new hot
pockets limited edition chili sauce
cheese dog and barbecue recipe bacon
burger the new easy way to bring that
authentic barbecue flavor home
i'd be castrated if i posted a video
like this
i posted a video for my own video game
and people wanted to [ __ ] wanted me to
die
oh yeah right that was so wild yeah that
was [ __ ] that was brutal and honestly
it was a fun game
i thought it was fun they could have
done better but like overall it was
pretty fun yeah i have a mobile game by
the way guys if you didn't know
ball rider
riding them balls so fast forward to
here [ __ ] smoke
pounds of crack later
talk about them hair legs
and i don't i don't like swearing i
think it's like kind of a
you know we should reserve those swear
words
when we're really really mad
we should only use well warmer bowie mad
bro you need to [ __ ] die using that
voice right now i mean it's so embarra
it just hurts my soul that this guy's
ranting about killing protesters and
then talking in this cutesy voice i mean
it's just it doesn't work dude i don't
like it
you need to die buddy you need to
[ __ ] eat some cyanide pills and die
you need to dig your own grave and bury
yourself in it
um
i mean it's funny there's so yeah that's
funny cuz i don't know maybe i'll do it
one day fun
not right now almost
a little sound effect there a little
boom a little bone moment that was me oh
that was you i thought about that i was
like so there was some editing
swear
i don't know why but this is the most
watched part right here
well we're about to find out early mad
it's this part oh we should only use
one more bowie match it's that part we
already watched um we should only use
swear words when we're very much
but kill those [ __ ] protesters carl
kill them till they're dead those
pedophiles
i mean it's funny this you know it's
funny cuz i don't know maybe i'll do it
one day fun
all right now almost
um
anyways dude
let me get some sleep bro i don't know
right now
okay so the reason i really i was so
excited well just it's all coincidence i
mean i said that uh in the politics he's
such an egomaniac he's here to to hype
up kyle rettenhaus he's literally spent
seven minutes of 13 sitting in his car
ranting about how he used to entertain
kids
what a [ __ ] lunatic
sounds like i was joking but kind of
kind of not because uh you know out of
nowhere for no reason my body is like oh
yeah i'm working with this guy already
i'm like oh my god i would love to meet
meet this kid and see how
how he's doing what what he was feeling
kind of get a sense of him
you know just to see because
people are so emotional they have such
strong opinions about people and they
were so quick to judge which
uh
we gotta learn and not do that
especially not if the what about blue
haired people bro
about protesters you were just saying
are we worthy of dying yeah good point
you you just could condemn them to death
bro and what have you learned about them
you think something
you should think the opposite just to be
safe you should be like okay i'm going
to be the opposite and just uh i'll
watch you guys do your little dance from
here and then see if you change your
mind just don't start out believing what
they leave nothing they're the goal is
not they don't have your best interests
at heart and they don't they don't dude
he he's curious to be better yeah
is straight up q and on he i have no
question
this guy's ready to give it all up for q
five star q general where we go where
tobiscus goes we all go or whatever
he never meets kyle
no not in the video what the [ __ ] yeah
video this is the whole video it's him
ranting unhinged yep
a manic rant i thought he was gonna go
meet him nah
well he does he doesn't film it no
what the [ __ ] i was waiting for him to
go do something his ass just sit in the
car the whole time yeah i came for a
vlog
dude
oh my god i feel like i got conned into
watching this [ __ ]
i'm not finishing this [ __ ]
look at all his recent videos are like
um
crack fueled rants from my car
that's awesome
holy [ __ ]
these views are [ __ ] scary this guy
was the king man
wow well to be fair his the effort he's
putting into these is l as a as close to
zero as you can get
is god and a-hole
talk more slow like
cheating
cancer can eat my balls but i hope it
doesn't
do you like july 4th
wait he's on tick tock now i'm just
going down to tobiscus hole here
um
where's this tick tock
people like this are always big on tick
tock somehow
man this guy's so aging he has a spread
shirt
oh it doesn't work
i have a stick talk yeah give me that
[ __ ] i want to see what the [ __ ] he's up
to on tick tock
i just sent him discord
tobiscus
250k
hibiscus with their hairy legs yeah you
know yesterday i made a video it was
really positive it was a little too
positive honestly so
yeah you know yesterday i made a video
it was really positive it was a little
too positive honestly so today i just
wanted to kind of balance that out with
a just a video a negative video i want
to say something negative about every
place in the world
uh you know let's see to the continents
let's do that again okay let's start uh
start with asia
[Music]
asia come on four-letter word
you have the biggest continent in the
world and you only have four letters to
the word in english
get out of freaking town there you go
asia okay australia
what are those you got what are those
utes you guys have those freaking car
trucks like they want to be el caminos
u-t-e-s look them up everybody else look
him up
i mean yeah no
you expect someone to actually want to
watch this i mean
this is like found footage of someone
who rants but to himself you know
holy [ __ ] tobiscus
that's scary
here this one has a lot of views 80 000
america many of us just found out a
couple crazy things not only did we have
our own stonehenge in georgia the
georgia guidestones but some knucklehead
blown to smithereens a couple days ago
so none of us even had a chance to visit
there's also a third thing this may be a
little more alarming is on the side of
each of these tablets was a game plan to
maintain the earth's population of
humans responsibly at a number under 500
million people
which brings a couple questions to my
mind is how do you responsibly
drop the population of humans
by 7 billion that's a bit of a drop and
2 more importantly if we only have 500
million people
is that still enough people for you why
is he do shooting at this angle
like it's a steering wheel on the right
side he's such a forced angle he's
trying to flex his tesla
like why are you talking to your back
seat dude
sustain a respectable career by posting
twerk videos on tick tock i hope so i
hope it's a very vulnerable angle i feel
like um
oh hi there didn't see in my back seat
my hair legs
all right that's it i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on with tobiskus but uh
god help that man or whatever i don't
know what he needs
he needs a a he needs a sponsor
he needs some milk
needs some milk jack and an ice cream
ice cream cone
you ever had an ice cream on a hot
summer day jack
oh god this looks crazy
uh the audio was removed
i mean it's crazy
sandwiches that's what i was gonna say i
never met someone who thinks so much
like me oh it's a it's a okay all right
there you have it guys tub is
the biggest youtuber one of the biggest
youtubers that ever lived
i got your word straight jack
from uh hot pockets to kyle rittenhouse
the journey of a lifetime
oh it's an advertisement so wait was he
actually paid for this
it says
i don't know no i think he just did this
for love of the game
cause he said
bro you know kyle rittenhouse's game
slaps hard though we should try it
you know
definitely dude you want to watch the
trailer for it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i was oh my god dude dude why the
headshot why the headshot you are so
[ __ ] bro your life is [ __ ] you're
being used so hard by all these
conservative [ __ ] freaks
your life is so [ __ ] dude
so kyle rittenhouse made a game
five bucks right or something like that
you might really look on the bottom you
might rece you might know me as the guy
who was recently acquitted no no no no
that's not what charges in the kenosha
you might know me as a guy who was
recently acquitted from all charges in
the kenosha self-defense case
[Music]
from the very beginning i did nothing
wrong
but that didn't stop the media from
smearing my name
it's time to fight back against the fake
news machine
this is why i'm launching the kyle
ridden house fake news turkey shoe video
game
[Music]
the media is nothing but a bunch of
turkeys with nothing better to do than
push their lying agenda and destroy
innocent people's lives so go to
rittenhousegame.com and pre-order the
game now and help me fund the lawsuits
and stop these fights
get the fake news
what the [ __ ] dude what
looks lit
can't wait
oh my god
for kyle
can't wait
let's see you can donate to kyle
um
this is like a good trumpian thing like
pay me to sue them
it's time to hold a media accountable
jack
you can send me money on paypal or
coinbase i have an update
go ahead
sorry this is off topic but we are in
the background of the ace family
official video yep i just let's go
time stamp time stamp time sam
we may be
this is the real [ __ ] yeah we may be in
it more but this i see me and dan and
cam on the swing right here so are they
calling anyone out in this or is it just
like a fun
i think abs just like going through it
right now i'm going through it yeah i
was just looking for us so wait where
are you guys
[Music]
go back
[Music]
get ready here it comes pause it
wait you're on the swing i'm on the
swing let it go again
wait keep going and one more one more oh
is that you here that's dan in the back
in the red
and the back swing on the wait where are
you guys
oh you're
he's looking at the he's not looking at
the foreground he's looking at the
background
wait you're not on the swing we're going
to understand it's in the back right
here
look at my monitor oh you guys are in
the back you're not even in the
foreground
like hold the phone hold the phone hold
the phone
how'd you even spot yourself on that
it's like you can't even see [ __ ] that's
where we were screaming at them okay so
so is this you guys here yes yeah so
that's uab right back here yeah yeah
okay interesting so that was the
videographer yep yeah wow
but it wasn't like i was rolling around
with it he wasn't trying to expose you
guys so here you guys go here's dan and
abe we've made it guys
yeah cameron that's cam and wait where's
cameron
oh there's camille yeah yeah and is this
you olivia yeah yeah oh [ __ ] dude the
whole fam's here and this is sam
no no no oh yeah she got that i was
inside waiting in the oh you got yeah
dude
anymore that's what i'm checking
nope
dude it kind of looks fun when they've
posted it man it looks like it was
happening
doesn't it
yeah it doesn't work
was that that many people
uh well this looks like it's at night so
it would have been after we left we left
right before sundown so
but um
yeah
okay wait i wanna hear what they have to
say
hey family as you can see it's the next
day we just wanna take a moment to thank
all of you beautiful ace family members
again you guys are coming through and
showing so much love and so you're
welcome you're very well thank you guys
so welcome thank you we truly truly are
very thankful for all i'ma drop a like
you guys i just want to say that leading
up to the event
obviously we you know started planning
this months ago and
we live in a time where people aren't
really doing events like these if not
ever i feel like
we're living in a time where people
don't want to leave their homes people
are afraid
there's you know terrible things
happening on the news and you know
things that are being shared across the
world every week
there was just something that happened a
couple of days ago i don't know i just
feel like i'm so grateful for every
single person who came to our no idea
what she's referring to there you go
there's so many things ace family
yes
i hope they see our video
you
know they might not just because from
the title and thumb they'll probably
assume it's just nothing but like just
somebody's got to tell him that we loved
it like the words got to get out too
yeah there will be like a highlight clip
yeah definitely they'll definitely see
it they'll see it somebody's gonna tell
them
okay contact us mcbrooms we want we want
that interview
thanks everyone for watching
you guys can suck a fat donut i'm gonna
suck a fat doughnut on uh wednesday yep
a big old prolapse donut yeah can we
make a donut that looks like a like
howie's prolapse anus sam you're nodding
yes absolutely can you do that yes yes
try to make it look like the prolapse
anus and i'll suck it done can't be
joking yes
sam sometimes sometimes i get mad
sometimes i get mad why do you get mad
we're going to look at that all day bro
and then we're going to watch you
but we can't show it but at least we can
show a donut who says we can't show a
donut yeah
yeah
i'm gonna eat it bro and you're gonna
eat it too you're gonna have a bite of
it fine we'll all take a bite of the fat
doughnut yeah we're all gonna suck a
donut
i'm gonna eat
and uh
sorry i know we're kind of wrapping up
but
austin shows how the event looked prior
to going inside
and it looks a lot more packed before
they move the meet and greet inside
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
okay so they do have their kids there oh
that's their kids yeah
that's what people were saying is that
earlier in the day their kids were gonna
give this so were they meeting one of
these to them i mean i hope not
but you would have just let's see
yeah these family members were here
first did the first ones what's your
name wrong first in line then they
he dabbed him up too bro yeah yeah
that's just how homies do it when you
see him in person he just comes to you
because he's a cool dude he just senses
aura he [ __ ]
yeah definitely maybe he's dope
i got you guys some guests oh thank you
so much i don't know these are our og
ace members right here they go
everywhere we go they always around
they're our number one support we love
them
all right so we made some adjustments
and we decided to have the rest of the
meet and greet indoors indoors in the
pavilion
contacted fema and they've helped us
all right all right guys thanks for
watching we will be back on wednesday
with another banger because that's all
we do baby nothing but bangers
right anything else we'll have a
prolapse uh anus donut for you to eat uh
we should do um our john henry um
you know man versus the machine cameron
versus the oh
that's so exciting for wednesday so we
could do that on wednesday um also what
we're gonna have to talk about um i just
saw some people mentioning in the chat
but did you see that news about the
uh
the girl from um
housewives salt lake city
wait which one what happened
the one that you brought up jen shaw
yeah jen shaw she was the one that got
raided yeah she just uh today plead
guilty uh to the whole thing and yo she
going to jail
probably
check it out
oh that's crazy when i got to texas hilo
so we'll have to we'll probably talk
about
that as well
well we gotta do that with ela cause
she's super passionate about the
housewives also we'll have to see how
interesting
it'll probably have some gold but you
know that um
aidan ross uh
like i think right now is um
interviewing uh cobra cobra tate oh i
heard about that stream or whatever is
it live right now
it might still be live i don't know oh
it just ended
apparently so i mean none of us have
seen that but if there's funny [ __ ] from
that we'll probably pull that we're
going to have a
very very oh my god
240 000 people just got exposed to
andrew tate sponsored by steak sponsored
by steak bro what the [ __ ] dude why i
just
dude why are you promoting this guy he's
a [ __ ] human trafficker dude what the
[ __ ] is this
what you were gonna say maybe no i'm
just saying we're gonna have a very
juicy week we're already starting to get
some feedback from some of the
commentary channels so
it's gonna be good i think um
i think this is gonna be good content
for us but bad outcome for the world
yeah probably
rich lux responded low oh my god h3 no
worries peace and love ace fest sucks
the house girl
but you had to buy tickets to win the
prize and had to pay yeah no [ __ ] you
have to go to the event to get prizes
and you had to pay for parking that
part's true that i don't like that but
yeah anyway peace and love from rich
rich lux who was banned by dan yeah
warren hate for me to you
well
peace and love to rich lux
or as we called him affectionately
rich
reach locks the house
did you just learn about the house
no no i knew it but i love it now i
liked him at first with the house thing
and then he did i i'm not going to say i
don't like i don't want any heat from
any of these guys i love
that just reach reach the house girl
that's it
whoa i can't wait to dig into this aidan
ross andrew tate [ __ ] man
[ __ ] me
mom
we are [ __ ] this world is so [ __ ]
if you drink but if you bring sparkly
while you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you let your girlfriend go out the
house what the [ __ ]
all right that's enough see you guys on
wednesday for another banger
because that's all we do baby
and you know it's gonna be off the rails
you know it will be and that's the title
of the show
yep
[Music]
you